welche woche heute nochmals sehr
inhaltsreich aufgrund des riesen etats
für arbeit und soziales größter
einzelposten jeanette klag es dort für
uns guten morgen nach berlin
ja guten morgen aus berlin hier aus dem
reichstagsgebäude tag 4 der
haushaltsberatung zum bundeshaushalt
2022 und in der tat das ist der
abschluss einer parlamentarischen woche
die nicht wie üblich bei
haushaltsberatungen also wieso er lange
und anstrengend auch für die
abgeordneten ist sondern es ist keine
gewöhnliche haushaltsberatung hier
gewesen das haben auch abgeordnete
während der debatten immer wieder betont
denn es ist der erste bundeshaushalt den
die ampel verantwortet aber vor allem
standen und stehen diese
haushaltsberatung unter dem eindruck des
angriffskriegs von russland gegen die
ukraine und auch der dortigen
humanitären lage und auch der
bundeshaushalt der etat ist und wird
beeinflusst vom krieg in der ukraine das
hat christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister deutlich gemacht
und bereits einen ergänzungs haushalt
angekündigt darin wird unter anderem
beispielsweise weitere hilfen für die
ukraine berücksichtigung finden aber
auch entlastungen für die bürgerinnen
und bürger heute bevor dann am
nachmittag das ganze haushaltsgesetz der
entwurf mit allen einzelplänen in die
weiteren beratung in die ausschüsse
überwiesen wird gibt es nochmal die
schlussrunde hier am mittag mit
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
und davor der etat des
familienministeriums steht hier auf der
tagesordnung und der große etat arbeit
und soziales 160 milliarden diese zahl
kann man ruhig noch mal nennen ausgaben
sind allein in diesem jahr geplant mehr
als ein drittel des gesamten
bundeshaushalts und da ist es doch gut
dass wir heute morgen zum interview
bevor es drinnen im plenarsaal losgeht
zwei abgeordnete bei uns haben die sich
mit arbeitsmarkt und sozialem bestens
auskennen darf einmal begrüßen so seine
fesche für die linke die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
und martin rosemann für die spd-fraktion
der sprecher für arbeit und soziales
terrors man vierter tag der
haushaltsberatung jetzt haben wir diese
woche in der generaldebatte auch in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte schon viel
gehört über schwerpunkte der ampel
klimaschutz energiesicherheit natürlich
die ukraine hilfe spielte eine rolle
aber auch die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundeswehr sozialpolitik spielte noch
nicht so eine rolle jetzt haben wir
heute die lesung aber trotz fällt auf
dass zentrale sozialpolitische vorhaben
gerade auch der spd nicht in der
budgetplanung vorkommen und auch nicht
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung
beispielsweise nichts über das
bürgergeld und nichts über die
kindergrundsicherung warum
weil bürgergeld und kindergrundsicherung
erst ab dem jahr 2023
relevant werden da gibt es noch keine
gesetze und wenn es keine gesetze gibt
dann ist das auch noch nicht reif und
befindet sich das im haushalt 2022 noch
nicht wieder es ist aber so dass wir ja
in der besonderen situation sind das wir
weil wir ja als ampel erst ende letzten
jahres ins amt gekommen sind wir sind ja
für 2022 in der vorläufigen
haushaltsführung wir machen jetzt in
haushalts 22 aber im bundeskabinett wird
bereits im juni der haushalt für 2023
dann beraten und da werden sich diese
projekte selbstverständlich wieder
finden ich war auch deswegen nicht nur
haushalt her ist sondern tatsächlich
alles fällt auf weil diese projekte die
ja sehr zentral sind auch für die spd
fraktion noch nicht angeschoben sind und
das sind ja sehr langfristige projekte
der sozialverband deutschland er hat
schon mal angesichts dieser
haushaltsberatung gewarnt dass die ampel
nicht beispielsweise ukraine hilfe
finanziell auflegt zu lasten der
sozialpolitik wie wollen sie diesen
eindruck entgegentreten es in der tat so
dass in einer krise die wir jetzt haben
dass da immer es darum geht sicherheit
zu garantieren und 23 hinsicht äußere
sicherheit innere sicherheit und
sozialer sicherheit gerade in der krise
geht es jetzt darum den sozialen
zusammenhalt zu sichern und zu
stabilisieren und das ist ja auch einer
der gründe warum wir jetzt bereits zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
haben mit dem wir gerade dafür sorgen
dass die gesellschaft jetzt zusammenhält
und besonders diejenigen entlasten die
besonders von den hohen energiepreisen
betroffen sind die arbeitende mitte und
menschen am unteren rand der
einkommensskala
auf das entlastungspaket was gestern das
zweite was jetzt gerade vorgestellt ist
kommen wir gleich noch mal was da die
sozial händlern man geht frau fesche von
ihrer fraktion hat man in dieser
haushaltswoche dutzendfach schon gehört
dass dieser haushalt ein
sozialpolitisches streichkonzert sei
jetzt haben gehört der etat 160
milliarden der soll wachsen bis 2026 auf
180 milliarden wo fehlt ihnen denn geld
für arbeit und soziales jetzt meine muss
man ja sehen dass der etat auch
rückläufig ist und zum anderen ist es so
dass wesentliche forderungen oder dinge
die wirklich die menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen entlasten würden sie uns
angesprochen bürgergeld oder eine
mindestrente wir haben die zunehmende
altersarmut dass sie überhaupt nicht im
haushalt abgebildet sind diese ganzen
forderungen also immens bürgergeld
mindestrente und eine erhöhung des
rentenniveaus nehmen würde wären wir
ungefähr bei 30 milliarden euro das ist
nicht da das geld angeblich aber auf der
anderen seite gibt man über nacht stellt
man sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro für ausrüstung zur verfügung und
wir sagen es muss was zum sozialen
zusammenhalt getan werden weil der
innere frieden natürlich auch elementar
ist und ich meine es ist ja angesprochen
worden mit den steigenden energiepreisen
die korona krise es waren insgesamt
insbesondere die niedrigen und die
mittleren einkommen die entsprechend
massiv belastet worden sind und dem
entlastungspaket kommen die rentnerinnen
minijobber studierende wären überhaupt
nicht berücksichtigt
heraus man darf ich ganz kurz noch
fragen zwischendurch weil wir wollen
dass auch für die zuschauer etwas
transparenter noch machen tatsächlich
wollen wir mal konkret machen an diesem
entlastungspaket 2 was gestern die ampel
vorgestellt hat da ist unter anderem
darin dass jeder erwerbstätige einmal
eine einmalzahlung von 300 euro bekommen
soll für jedes kind gibt der staat
einmalig 100 euro empfänger von
sozialleistungen erhalten
einmalzahlungen von 200 euro statt 100
euro das hört sich ein bisschen so an es
ist für alle was dabei und sozial
gestaffelt ist doch da eigentlich nicht
warum hat man alle entlastet und nicht
gezielt kleinere und sozial schwache das
stimmt ja so nicht also wir fokussieren
auf diejenigen die besonders betroffen
sind von den hohen energiepreisen
und sie müssen beide entlastungspaket
das entlastungspaket 1 das ja sogar vor
beginn das ukraine kriegs schon auf den
weg gebracht wurde und das
entlastungspaket zwei jetzt gestern
zusammen betrachten und dann haben wir
zwei maßnahmen die sich besonders an
leute mit geringem einkommen richten das
eine ist die einmalzahlung diese schon
angesprochen haben ursprünglich waren
100 euro verabredet jetzt hat man
verabredet dass weitere 100 euro dazu
kommen und das zweite ist der
heizkostenzuschuss für bezieherinnen
bezieher von wohngeld und unter anderem
übrigens auch vom bafög und deswegen
stimmt es nicht dass studierende nicht
berücksichtigt sind und diesen
heizkostenzuschuss den haben wir hier
schon ins gesetz gegossen und der hat
sich im parlamentarischen verfahren ja
noch mal verdoppelt das heißt wir
konzentrieren uns sehr wohl auf
geringverdiener und bei diesen 300 euro
und auch bei den 100 euro für jedes kind
ist es ja so dass das dann bei der
einkommensteuer entsprechend verrechnet
werden das heißt gutverdiener bekommen
unterm strich weniger menschen mit
geringerem einkommen bekommen unter dem
strich mehr auf hersteller herr rose man
sagt doch sozial schwache und auch
kleinere einkommen profitieren und in
der tat zumindest könnten diese
maßnahmen ja sehr schnell und
unbürokratisch rücken oder es ist ja
auch nicht so dass wir sagen es ist
komplett in die falsche richtung gedacht
aber es ist halt schon sowie hosen man
gesagt hat dass die 300 euro jeder
bekommt und natürlich wird über die
steuer entsprechend auch wieder
besteuert trotzdem ist es doch
eigentlich nur sinn wenn zum beispiel
jemand wie ich als bundestagsabgeordnete
auch davon profitiert also ich finde ab
einem bestimmten einkommen ist es
definitiv nicht nötig und das geld fehlt
natürlich bei den menschen die es
dringend nötig haben also selbst wenn
man jetzt bei den hartz iv
empfängerinnen wissen ja auch menschen
die zu niedrige löhne haben die
aufstocken rentnerinnen und rentner die
in der grundsicherung sind mit 200 euro
da ist es doch nicht getan also die sind
doch jetzt in der pandemie schon seit
zwei jahren über die maßen belastet und
das ist auch der vorwurf den ich mach
das wäre problemlos möglich gewesen
zumindest das bürgergeld kinder sich
grundsicherung verstehe ich noch das ist
relativ komplex aber das bürgergeld
entsprechend zu erhöhen so dass diese
menschen dauerhaft wirklich in würde
leben können und dafür sind mindestens
600 euro im monat möglich das sagen auch
alle sozial verbringen weil sie immer
vergessen frau ferschl ist das wenn sie
den regelsatz zu erhöhen gibt es
natürlich argumente dafür dass die dann
gleichzeitig das steuerliche
existenzminimum
richtig dann profitiere aber dann
profitieren sie doch auch wiederum da
ist es doch viel besser wäre
doch viel genauer mit einmal an ich will
nur mal sagen ich glaube kann die linke
fährt auch mal ein bisschen darüber
nachdenken das bürgergeld da geht es ja
nicht darum ob jetzt zehn euro mehr oder
weniger sondern da geht und 100 tagen
da sagen wir noch mal auf den schaffen
sie nicht über nacht das bürgergeld wird
hartz 4 ersetzen und da geht's ich sage
es noch mal um den kulturwandel in den
jobcentern um eine unterstützung auf
augenhöhe wir wollen ja auch die ganze
förderlandschaft nochmal verbessern sehr
viel mehr auf weiterbildung setzen neue
instrumente wie begleitendes coaching
und aufsuchende sozialarbeit und
wirklich eine zielgenaue und passgenaue
unterstützung
die machen sie nicht über nacht die muss
gründlich gemacht werden die muss
übrigens auch so gemacht werden dass sie
dann tatsächlich auch in den jobcentern
umgesetzt und erreicht er nicht dass sie
ein paar sätzen nur ins gesetz ich würde
trotzdem noch mal ganz kurz nachfragen
herr rose man es sind tatsächlich
einmalzahlung also auch was jedes jeder
ist für jedes kind soll 100 euro bezahlt
werden dann gibt es ja noch dieses
verbilligte pnv ticket für den
nahverkehr drei monate lang für neun
euro was passiert nach den
einmalzahlungen denn die energiepreise
auch die lebensmittelpreise werden
wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell runter
gehen wir werden das weiter beobachten
und wir werden gegebenenfalls auch
nochmal handeln also es muss ja nicht
das letzte entlastungspaket gewesen sein
ich sage aber auch die hohen
energiepreise im moment haben auch viel
mit spekulationen zu tun wir haben es ja
nicht mit einer realen rohstoffknappheit
zu tun sondern wir haben es ja mit
spekulationen darauf zu tun das sehen
sie wenn sie zum beispiel den
weltmarktpreis für ein barrel öl nehmen
der ja gesunken ist aber an der
zapfsäule ist es nicht
dass ich es nicht bemerkbar gemacht und
das ist ja auch der grund dafür dass wir
auch gesagt kam verabredet haben gestern
dass wir auch wettbewerbsrechtliche
maßnahmen auch anwenden wollen um zu
verhindern dass mineralölkonzerne sich
die gewinne mit diesen spekulationen
einfach in die tasche stecken und auch
da werden wir ansetzen damit es eben
nicht bei diesen hohen energiepreisen
bleibt es macht ja keinen sinn dass wir
steuergeld das wir alle mühsam
erwirtschaften müssen in die hand nehmen
damit es nachher diejenigen die mit
diesen preisen spekulieren am ende noch
einen größeren reibach machen
zum teil
noch eine frage hubertus heil hat
gestern angekündigt dass die
erwerbsminderungsrente erhöhen wird drei
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner
sollen davon profitieren ab 2027
das müsste ihnen doch eigentlich
gefallen frau herrscht das ist
tatsächlich ein schritt in die richtige
richtung auf der anderen seite erleben
wir dass zum beispiel jetzt im haushalt
der sonderzuschuss für die rentenkasse
dieses jahr überhaupt nicht überwiesen
wird das heißt die rücklagen schmelzen
und das ist durchaus davon auszugehen
dass es zu rentenkürzungen kommt und das
kritisieren wir natürlich weil es dann
nicht entsprechend die sicherheiten gibt
und man sieht auch dass jetzt wieder die
hand an den sozialstaat gelegt wird in
der bundesagentur für arbeit im übrigen
das gleiche die steuerzuschüsse werden
nicht gegeben sondern es wird lediglich
offensichtlich über einen kredit
finanziert und da ist die große sorge
dass jetzt wieder hand an den
sozialstaat gelegt wird wir werden dazu
gleich in der debatte noch einiges
erfahren ich möchte die wenigen minuten
immer noch habe noch eine renten kürzen
darf ich noch einen seit jahren zusammen
sagt sein rennen also die machen ja hier
angst rentenkürzungen drohne und
überhaupt nicht ganz im gegenteil
gestern kann mir die zahlen raus wie die
rentenerhöhung wenn airbus fallen wollen
fünf prozent über fünf prozent im westen
und judo 6 prozent - zum ersten juli ist
das angekündigt die rente ist
tatsächlich ein großes thema da müssen
ein eigenes interview zu führen wir
werden da in der debatte noch einiges zu
hören ich würde ganz gerne mit ihnen
beiden weil es ein aktuelles thema ist
und viele menschen darauf schauen die
flüchtlinge die geflüchteten die aus der
ukraine zu uns nach deutschland kommen
da hat der bundesarbeitsminister
angekündigt nach der akutphase die
menschen haben erst einmal andere sorgen
die müssen erstmal versorgt werden
unterkommen und zur ruhe kommen nach der
akutphase will er es ermöglichen das
geflüchtete schnell in arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden können allerdings
jetzt trifft sich hubertus heil nächste
woche mit gewerkschaften und mit der
wirtschaft private unternehmer
beispielsweise hier in berlin waren
schon wesentlich schneller die haben
eine plattform eine online-jobbörse
eröffnet da sind schon über 7.000 offene
stellen 20.000 zugriffe am tag mehr raus
man hinke politik da ein bisschen
hinterher nein es ist ja super wenn die
privatwirtschaft der initiative das
zeigt ja dass es einen bedarf an
arbeitskräften gibt und da geht es jetzt
da und da kommen viele auch gut
ausgebildete vor allem frauen aus der
ukraine hierher und es kann uns helfen
bei der bewältigung dieses mangels an
fachkräften aber auch an arbeitskräften
zum beispiel in der gastronomie und
deswegen ist es ist es wunderbar müssen
politik und wirtschaft hand in hand
arbeiten und jede initiative es
hilfreich welche weichenstellungen frau
fesche sind jetzt wichtig um die
ukrainerinnen es sind überwiegend frauen
hier gut in den arbeitsmarkt integrieren
zu können können sofern sie wir wissen
nicht wie lange die menschen bleiben wir
arbeiten möchten im wesentlichen zwei
aus meiner sicht heraus zum einen ist es
dringend nötig dass der arbeitsmarkt
reguliert wird weil gerade zum beispiel
der bereich gastronomie der angesprochen
worden ist wir sehr viele prekäre
beschäftigungsverhältnisse haben
minijobs überstunden und so weiter und
ich finde dass das nicht das jetzt auf
dem rücken der menschen die aus der
ukraine hierher fliegen entsprechend die
arbeitsbedingungen weiter in diesem
zustand bleiben können und der zweite
punkt ist dass ich glaube es ist extrem
wichtig die infrastruktur zu schaffen
also wohnraum schulen kita um
entsprechend dann auch die kinder die
frauen in entsprechend versorgen zu
können und es wäre natürlich auch ein
wesentlicher schritt um die konjunktur
anzukurbeln und das würde insgesamt
helfen um auch den arbeitsmarkt zu
stabilisieren
dass ein blick auf das was uns die
nächsten wochen noch beschäftigen wird
jetzt schauen wir erstmal rein in die
haushaltsberatung ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für seine fesche für die linke
und martin rosemann für die spd dass ihr
heute morgen sich die zeit genommen
haben zu diesem interview und wir
verehrte zuschauer schauen in dem
plenarsaal denn die sitzung die wird
jetzt in diesen minuten eröffnet werden
und es steht an der große etat arbeit
und soziales
der bundesarbeitsminister
der wird diese debatte eröffnen er wird
seinen etat hier sehen wir schon auf der
regierungsbank er wird seinen etat hier
in dieser ersten lesung
vorstellen
und dann wird es die aussprache geben
und jetzt hören wir erst mal die
eröffnung
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich wünsche ihnen allen
einen guten morgen die sitzung ist
eröffnet
vorab teile ich ihnen mit dass sich der
ältestenrat in seiner gestrigen sitzung
einvernehmlich darauf verständigt hat
das ab der kommenden sitzungswoche
wieder regelmäßig die tage von dienstag
bis freitag als präsenztage nach § 14
absatz 1 des abgeordnetengesetzes gelten
wir setzen nun die
haushaltsberatungen fort für die heutige
aussprache haben wir am dienstag eine
redezeit von insgesamt vier stunden und
30 minuten beschlossen wir kommen nun
zum geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales und das wort hat für die
bundesregierung der bundesminister für
arbeit und soziales hubertus heil
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin schön dass sie wieder
da sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
putins überfall auf die ukraine zwingt
uns in vielerlei hinsicht zur
neuausrichtung unserer politik in den
letzten vier wochen haben wir als
bundesregierung schnell und entschlossen
notwendige entscheidung getroffen aber
ich sage auch putins kriegt man der
damen und herren kann und wird nicht
dafür sorgen dass wir unsere haltung und
unsere werte aufgeben neue
bundesregierung
neue bundesregierung steht dafür ein
dass wir eine starke und solidarische
gesellschaft sind und bleiben nach innen
und nach außen gerade jetzt kommt es
darauf an den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt zu festigen gerade jetzt
geht es darum dass sich alle auf soziale
sicherheit in unserem land verlassen
können gerade jetzt geht es darum dass
wir besonders diejenigen nicht aus dem
blick verlieren wie es auch sonst in
anderen zeit nicht leicht haben wir
werden in diesen schweren zeiten die
werte unserer sozialen demokratie nicht
preisgeben meine damen und herren dass
unsere feste überzeugung
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
mit dieser haltung müssen wir jetzt
diese krise meistern und das bedeutet
wir müssen klare prioritäten setzen sie
ist als meine aufgabe als arbeits und
sozialminister an
vor allen dingen dafür zu sorgen dass
bei all dem was wir tun sozialer
ausgleich herrscht und ich sage ihnen
ganz deutlich wo notwendig werde ich die
soziale gerechtigkeit in meinem land
auch strafen
drei dinge gilt es jetzt anzupacken
erster dafür zu sorgen dass auch in
dieser neuen wirtschaftskrise durch
sichere arbeitsplätze soziale stabilität
entsteht und deshalb sage ich ihnen an
dieser stelle wir haben in der pandemie
den arbeitsmarkt robust durch die krise
gebracht und ich bin diesem bundestag
dankbar dass wir in den letzten tagen es
geschafft haben auch nochmal kurzarbeits
regeln anzupassen mein ziel ist auch
durch diese krise den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt robust zu bringen wir
werden um jeden arbeitsplatz kämpfen
zweitens es geht es darum die sozialen
und die wirtschaftlichen folgen ab
zufrieden wir sehen heute massive
preissteigerungen nicht nur an der
zapfsäule sondern bei heizkosten bei
stromkosten auch bei lebensmitteln
wenn wir jetzt denen nicht helfen die in
not sind dann verpassen wir unsere
aufgaben dann wird es schnell kalt in
unserem land und deswegen haben wir in
den letzten wochen entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht um härten abzufedern
nicht mit der gießkanne sondern sozial
ausgewogen mit dem heizkostenzuschuss
den kinder sofort zuschlag den zuschlag
für menschen in der grundsicherung der
erhöhung der steuerlichen des
steuerlichen grundfreibetrages mit der
abschaffung der eeg-umlage vorgestern
nacht hat die koalition noch mal eine
große schippe draufgelegt mit weiteren
entlastungen für arbeitnehmer und
arbeitnehmern und selbstständigen seiner
energie kostenpauschale in höhe von 300
euro als zuschuss zum gehalt
beziehungsweise selbständige als absolut
von der steuern mit den familien
zuschuss in höhe von 100 euro für jedes
kind in deutschland mit der verdoppelung
der einmalzahlung auf 200 euro für
erwachsene leistungsberechtigte in den
sozialen grundsicherungssystem und mit
weiteren maßnahmen zur mobilität ich
sage weil das ein thema ist von vielen
diesen maßnahmen werden übrigens
rentnerinnen und da profitieren in der
grundsicherung wird der zuschlag auch
für die rentnerin drin da gezahlt in der
grundsicherung sind beim
heizkostenzuschuss sind 46 prozent
derjenigen die davon profitieren werden
rentnerinnen und rentner von vielen
anderen dingen auch wir kümmern uns um
die die es schwer haben in dieser zeit
und darauf kann sich jeder verlassen
ihre kolleginnen kollegen diese
solidarität
die brauchen aber auch jene das ist mein
dritter punkt jetzt als geflüchtete bei
uns schutz suchen da geht es erst einmal
um die akute versorgung der menschen
hier leisten viele bürgerinnen und
bürger in unserem land großartig
ehrenamtliche und hauptamtliche und ich
glaube ich spreche im namen des gesamten
hauses das er dafür hat sich dank sein
die menschen die vor putins krieg
fliehen aus der ukraine die brauchen
humanitäre hilfe und sofortige hilfe die
brauchen aber oft auch eine dauerhafte
bleibe perspektiven dafür müssen wir und
werden wie einen schnellen zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt schaffen sprach und
integrationskurse haben wir geöffnet
aber wir brauchen auch schul und kita
plätze und wir müssen einen weg finden
die qualifikationen die viele menschen
auch mit sich bringt schnell
anzuerkennen ich werde deshalb in der
kommenden woche wirtschaft
gewerkschaften wohlfahrtsverbände bund
und länder an einen tisch holen um über
arbeitsmarkt integration zu sprechen
alle müssen jetzt an einem tisch und
alle müssen an einem strang ziehen
du willst mir mal sagen es geht in
erster linie humanitäre hilfe
aber es geht auch darum da wo menschen
die chance haben zu arbeiten ihnen diese
möglichkeit auch zu schaffen ich sage
aber auch an dieser stelle sehr deutlich
wir werden als gesellschaft nicht
zulassen dürfen dass in dieser situation
die not von geflüchteten von
scharlatanen ausgerottet wird und
deshalb auch eine klare ansage wir
müssen und werden dafür sorgen dass die
menschen die so viel durchlitten haben
jetzt nicht opfer von abzocke oder
ausbeutung auch im arbeitsleben
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben es in der pandemie gesehen und
erlebt unser sozialstaat ist die
tragende säule für sozialen zusammenhalt
in unserem land für eine starke und
widerstandsfähige gesellschaft nach
innen und nach außen und deswegen sage
ich ganz klar wir werden es nicht
zulassen dass diese krise missbraucht
wird den sozialstaat zu schwächen ja es
ist richtig wir müssen und wir werden
mehr in die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
und die äußere sicherheit investieren
ich unterstütze das ausdrücklich aber
wir müssen auch in die menschen und die
soziale sicherheit investieren es darf
kein entweder oder geben denn wir
brauchen beides meine damen und herren
wir
äußere sicherheit und inneren und
sozialen frieden und wir dürfen nicht
entgegen rüstungen aus spielen in dieser
gesellschaft und übrigens auch nicht
geflüchtet dagegen einheimische das ist
dass solche als interessant und
gerade deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
andere aufgaben nicht vernachlässigt wir
werden den mindestlohn zum ersten
oktober auf 12 euro erhöhen damit
diejenigen die den laden am laufen hat
die hart arbeiten dieser gesellschaft
tatsächlich den lohn bekommen der ihnen
auch zusteht
deshalb ist es übrigens auch richtig
dass wir die renten stabil halten und
zwar für alle generationen und deshalb
ist es auch richtig dass und es um das
thema fachkräfte um die frage der
ausbildung der qualifizierung kümmern
damit die arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer
von heute auch die chance haben in
zeiten des wandels die arbeit von morgen
zu machen und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir für mehr respekt und mehr
soziale sicherheit sorgen mit der
einführung beispielsweise der
kindergrundsicherung und dem neuen
bürgergeld meine damen und herren die
krise zu meistern und für sozialen
fortschritt zu sorgen das ist der
gemeinsame anspruch von spd bündnis 90
und den grünen in der ampelkoalition
und das gilt und dafür werde ich
arbeiten erst recht was habe ich gesagt
das ist so selbstverständlich für mich
für fdp spd und grünen
ich kann ihnen das ernsthaft ich kann
mir das auch ernsthaft nachweisen dass
der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner schon vor dem
koalitionsausschuss deutlich gemacht hat
dass wir beispielsweise zuschläge
weitere auf die grundsicherung brauchen
dafür bin ich ihm sehr dankbar diese
koalition findet zusammen und tut das
richtige und dafür bin ich ihnen als fdp
besonders dank bei der mittelschule
meine damen und herren ich sage es noch
mal unterstreichen wir sind in
ernsthaften zeiten wir stehen vor sehr
großen herausforderungen
und wir müssen darauf achten dass unsere
gesellschaft diese krise
widerstandsfähig übersteht und dass wir
halt und stabilität übrigens auch geben
für die vielen veränderungen die nach
dieser krise auch noch stattfindet
werden und deshalb kann man dich
wirtschaftlichen erfolg ökologische
vernunft und soziale gerechtigkeit
gegeneinander ausspielen wir setzen auf
digitalen fortschritt wir setzen auf
ökologischen fortschritt aber das geht
nur mit sozialem fortschritt in
deutschland dafür arbeitete herzlichen
danke
sagt hubertus heil der minister für
arbeit und soziales sein etat nicht die
rente gegen rüstung ausspielen
tatsächlich war ja innerhalb dieser
haushaltswoche viel die rede von der
verteidigungsfähigkeit der bundeswehr
wegen dieses 100 milliarden
angekündigt
aber immer noch ist der posten rente mit
über 100 milliarden deckels posten
überhaupt im haushalt
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren es ist krieg in europa
dieser krieg berührt bewegt
erschüttert uns im herzen
um zu herzen öffnen unsere türen um die
vielen geflüchteten willkommen zu heißen
und schutz zu bieten und es ist
beeindruckend wie viele helfen beim
spendensammeln beim transport von
hilfsgütern in erste anlaufstellen oder
gemeinschaftsunterkünften und es sind
wieder die ehrenamtlichen die
wohlfahrtsverbände und organisationen
die hier an vorderster front stehen und
einfach anpacken es ist großartig ein
herzliches dankeschön an alle
helferinnen und helfer
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir helfen versorgen organisieren wir
bluten schutzräume für die vielen
geflohenen die mütter mit ihren kindern
die große zahl an älteren oder menschen
mit behinderungen sie sollen und sie
dürfen hier bei uns ankommen unterkommen
und sich sicher fühlen und wir wollen
gerade kindern und jugendlichen
möglichst schnell wieder so ein kleines
stück weit normalität geben deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine schnelle
integration in kita und schule
wir brauchen auch eine psychosoziale
betreuung denn das was man erlebt im
krieg und auf der flucht das ist etwas
das lange nachwirkt und ja die die
können und wollen die den kopf frei
haben
denen bieten wir auch sprachkurse an
denen bieten wir die
arbeitsmarktintegration am mit einem
breiten dienstleistungs und förderungs
angebot der bundesagentur für arbeit wir
stehen insgesamt vor einer großen
humanitären aufgabe in die wir gestellt
sind das ein gewaltiger kraftakt und das
gelingt nur gemeinsam gemeinsam mit den
kommunen vor ort mit den ländern und
auch mit dem bund und der bund hier
seiner verantwortung gerecht werden denn
es geht um eine faire lastenverteilung
bei den kosten und auch bei der
verteilung der geflüchteten auf die
länder und innerhalb der europäischen
union und dazu bedarf es einer
systematischen und lückenlosen
registrierung hier ist der bund am zug
er muss seiner verantwortung auch an
dieser stelle gerecht werden
der krieg hat tiefgreifende folgen
humanitäre und wirtschaftliche die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen sind
immens und werden jeden tag sichtbarer
lieferketten brechen zusammen notwendige
rohstoff für vielen und das führt zu
produktionsstopps zur kurzarbeit viele
arbeitsplätze sind bedroht es war
notwendig und richtig dass die
bundesregierung die kurzarbeiterregelung
erweitert das erkennen wir ausdrücklich
an sie haben nachgebessert bei der
zeitarbeit auch bei der möglichkeit die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge wieder zu
ersetzen jetzt
müssen sie dafür sorgen dass die
unternehmen möglichst eine
planungssicherheit in diesen bereichen
tatsächlich auch haben das tut not die
kurzarbeit ist ein gutes ein schnell
wirksames und werden das auch in der
pandemie gesehen auch ein teures
instrument das wissen wir und die
kurzarbeit alleine wird nicht ausreichen
um arbeitsplätze zu schützen wir
brauchen passgenaue lösungen gerade für
unsere energieintensiven betriebe die ja
zum teil schon ihre produktion
eingestellt haben und das was die ampel
hier beschlossen hat hilft nicht weiter
mit dem energie geld wird er einmal zahl
mit der kraftstoffsteuer all das hilft
dem produzierenden gewerbe nicht es ist
zu wenig und es ist zu kurz wir brauchen
eine echte entlastung der wirtschaft ein
hilfspaket das auch überbrückungshilfen
umfassen muss hier muss die
bundesregierung das richtige und
notwendige tun uns jetzt in diesem
bereich
die wirtschaft unsere arbeitsplätze
brauchen unterstützung auch die menschen
glauben es millionen sind aufs auto
angewiesen um zur arbeit zu kommen um
einzukaufen um das familienleben zu
organisieren damit die kinder oma und
opa besuchen können oder dass sie am
vereinsleben wieder teilhaben können wir
brauchen ja eine starke soziale
abfederung der krise und die
beschlossenen maßnahmen der ampel helfen
an dieser stelle ja sie reichen jedoch
nicht aus und es sehr interessant wenn
man mal im vorfeld es ging ja auch durch
die presse man sieht wie das
bundesarbeitsministerium offenbar
kraftstoff rabatte oder die abschläge
auf die energie steuer bewertet
wird dann typischerweise gesagt
diejenigen mit höherem einkommen die
sind auch mehr mobil und unterwegs aber
erstaunlich ist ja vor allem dass man
dann ratschläge gibt beispielsweise wenn
man so etwas macht bei den steuern diese
drunter setzt das gebe kein anreiz zum
sparen steht da obwohl solche auch
kurzfristig umsetzbar wären und da gibt
es gleich ein rad hinterher man könnte
ja statt 110 km/h 90 km h fahren jetzt
bin ich im ländlichen raum unterwegs auf
landstraßen auf bundesstraßen muss kann
dass man da 110 fährt also ebenfalls das
zeigt wir brauchen keine verhaltens
ratschläge aus dem aus des
bundesarbeitsministeriums sondern wir
brauchen tragfähige vorschläge und diese
haben wir unser breites und ohne
spürbare
steuersenkungen bei der energiekosten
das natürlich auch den mehrwertsteuer
umfassen muss drei monate ist viel zu
kurz auch gesprungen das was sie jetzt
beschlossen aber natürlich ist es
notwendig die pendlerpauschale zu
erhöhen auch ab dem ersten kilometer
entlasten sie die bürgerinnen und bürger
helfen sie den bürgerinnen und bürger in
dieser schweren situation das ist das
was jetzt not damit wir hier gut durch
diese krisensituation kommen dafür steht
die union
sagt stephan stracke der sprecher für
arbeit und soziales der unionsfraktion
das kurzarbeitergeld hat er angesprochen
unternehmen können erleichterungen beim
kurzarbeitergeld nach derzeitiger
rechtslage noch bis ende juli in
anspruch nehmen vor allem jahr
erfolgreich rona pandemie abzufedern war
das nochmal verlängert worden und
hubertus heil hat angekündigt dass er
einen vereinfachten zugang das
kurzarbeitergeld es auch wegen der
ukraine krise sich vorstellen kann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen gestern
haben wir uns als ampel auf das zweite
große entlastungspaket in nur wenigen
wochen verständigt und lieber herr
stracke vielleicht konzentrieren sich
einmal auf das was wir hier debattieren
natürlich ist nicht jeder einzelne punkt
in diesem entlastungspaket auch mein
persönlicher favorit ich persönlich
hätte die spritpreis bremse zum beispiel
nicht in der form umgesetzt ich hätte
gerne das geld genommen die an kleine
einkommen gegeben ich hätte gerne das
geld genommen um es an menschen in der
grundsicherung zu geben für die die es
tatsächlich brauchen anstatt dass ein
großer einkommen die beim tanken dann
auch noch davon profitieren zu bekommen
aber aber darf ich ihnen das sagen es
geht hier um was anderes in einer
solchen situation in einer solchen krise
in der wir uns gerade befinden
da kommt es darauf an am ende
kompromisse zu finden da kommt es am
ende darauf an dass man verantwortung
übernimmt und ich bin ich freue mich
freue mich sehr darüber und bin froh
darüber dass wir das als ampel genauso
geschafft haben und dass wir gemeinsam
auch dieses zweite entlastungs paket
verabschiedet haben und dass wir das
jetzt gemeinsam umsetzen
100 euro für menschen in der
grundsicherung wegen corona 100 euro für
menschen in der grundsicherung
wegen der ukraine krise und der kosten
noch mal 100 euro für jedes kind gerade
auch für kinder in der grundsicherung
und darauf werden wir achten bei der
umsetzung weitere 20 euro dann im
weiteren verlauf an kinder in armut 270
euro heizkostenzuschuss und nochmal 300
euro energiepreis pauschale für
erwerbstätige das ist die gezielte
unterstützung das ist das was ankommt
und das ist das was wir jetzt genau in
diesem moment brauchen und hinzu kommt
und das ist mir wichtig hinzu kommt wir
schaffen damit den konkreten einstieg in
ein energie geld das konzept wird jetzt
ausgearbeitet das konzept wird im
nächsten jahr umgesetzt und genau daran
zeigen wir dass bei uns energieeffizienz
die frage dass der energie entlastung
die frage der entlastung der kleinen
einkommen und all das zusammen gehörten
das schafft diese ampel hier mit diesen
beiden entlastungs paketen und das ist
hervorragend so
unsere solidarität in diesen
krisenzeiten die muss auch denen
menschen gelten die jetzt zu uns kommen
die wegen des kriegs in der ukraine zu
uns kommen wir werden diesen menschen
schutz bieten jeder und jedem einzelnen
wir werden denen eine unterkunft bieten
und wir werden ihnen alles bieten was zu
einem würdigen leben dazugehört und noch
mehr wenn sie das möchten werden wir in
eine perspektive bieten und eine neue
heimat hier bei uns und an dieser stelle
ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt am anfang
investieren dass wir ausreichend mittel
für sprachkurse zur verfügung stellen
und dann wird es gut für alle seiten
denn wir brauchen diese menschen wir
brauchen diese talente diese menschen
können teil unserer gesellschaft sein
die können hier wahnsinnig viel leisten
und ich sage ihnen wenn wir jetzt
investieren
dann wird sich das für alle und für uns
hier in deutschland in einigen jahren
zehn mal auszahlen deswegen sollten wir
genau das jetzt in diesem haushalt tun
putins angriffskrieg die steigenden
preise die vielen geflüchteten all diese
aufgaben all diese krisen passieren vor
dem hintergrund dass wir immer noch mit
den sozialen fragen und den sozialen
problemen der korona krise kämpfen das
kurzarbeitergeld hat in den vergangenen
jahren massenhaft entlassungen
verhindert in der spitze und das muss
man sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen
die diese zahl in der spitze waren über
sechs millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
die bundesagentur für arbeit hat an
dieser stelle enormes geleistet und ich
finde dass es einen moment in dem man
auch mal sagen kann danke an die
sachbearbeiterinnen und sachbearbeiter
an die tausenden von leuten dpa
zusammengezogen wurden um dieses geld
schnell und unkompliziert auszuzahlen
ohne all dieses engagement werden wir
nie so gut durch die krise gekommen
wir sehen aber gleichzeitig dass die
krise nicht zu ende sind und dass wir in
einer großen phase der unsicherheit
jetzt über diesen haushalt debattieren
deswegen ist es gut dass eine
ergänzungsabgabe wird und angesichts der
großen aufgaben bei geflüchteten bei der
entlastung von menschen bei der weiteren
finanzierung der ba und der kurzarbeit
müssen diese ganzen fragen im ergänzungs
haushalt an schlicht ich dass es in
diesem ergänzungs haushalt dann nochmal
berücksichtigung führen locken
wir kämpfen mit krisen wir kämpfen mit
großen krisen ich habe das gerade
beschrieben aber eines darf in dieser
phase nicht in vergessenheit geraten wir
dürfen nicht den blick für die zukunft
verlieren die klimakrise die klimakrise
und ich sage ihnen was das bedeutet die
klimakrise warten nicht und wenn wir
nicht aufpassen wenn wir jetzt nicht
handeln dann wird diese klimakrise bald
zu einer klimakatastrophe werden heute
gehen tausende menschen tausende junge
leute in ganz deutschland in ganz in der
ganzen welt auf die straße um für ein
anderes wirtschaften ein fossil freies
wirtschaften einzutreten sie tun das mit
recht wir müssen darauf antworten und
das bedeutet auch dass wir den
arbeitsmarkt
transformieren schon jetzt suchen so
viele unternehmen nach nachhaltigen
lieferketten nach klimaneutrale
produktion und das muss man mit großer
ehrlichkeit angehen das wird dazu führen
dass nicht jeder job dass nicht jeder
produktionszweig diese umstellung
überleben wird ja das ist korrekt die
produktion von verbrennungsmotoren für
die masse hat keine zukunft da werden
wir wegkommen müssen aber viele neue
jobs viele grüne jobs nachhaltige jobs
entstehen menschen werden gebraucht an
anderer stelle sie werden in der
elektrotechnik gebraucht sie werden in
digitalen produktionsprozessen gebraucht
sie werden bei tesla ein grün heilige
brun bei bmw in berlin und in münchen
sie werden in hannover bei vw gebraucht
und genauso die ganze in den ganzen
zulieferbetrieben wir grüne und wir als
ampel wir treiben diesen digitalen
transformationsprozess diesen
klimaneutralen transformationsprozess
voran so dass gute chancen dass gute
chancen für alle menschen daraus
entsteht und das ist das was fortschritt
ausmacht das ist das was diese koalition
tut und genau deswegen ist es auch an
der stelle wichtig dass wir die
bundesagentur für arbeit jetzt nicht mit
schulden zurück lassen denn sie wird
gebraucht als zentraler transformations-
akteur für die zukunft sie muss sich
darauf konzentrieren können dass die
pionierinnen und pioniere die sich jetzt
auf den weg machen die jetzt sagen wir
gehen in diese neue zeit des
wirtschaftens sind diese neue zeit des
wohlstandes dass diese menschen jetzt
die begleitung finden deswegen werden
wir die bundestag bundesagentur für
arbeit nicht mit schulden zurück lassen
sondern anständig ausstatten um diese
aufgaben der zukunft auch wahrzunehmen
ein letzter hund die umbrüche und die
chancen die umbrüche die wir haben
müssen auch in unseren anderen projekten
dazu führen dass wir die chancen in den
mittelpunkt stellen das gilt auch wenn
wir endlich uns daran machen das system
hartz 4 zu überwinden teil davon ist
dass teilhabechancen gesetz zu
entfristen damit wir
langzeitarbeitslosen neue wege in die
gesellschaft und den arbeit bieten das
geht aber nur wenn wir auch dafür
ausreichend geld zur verfügung stellen
und auch das werden wir machen dieser
haushalt dieses dieser haushalt ist der
erste der ampel koalition lieber herr
minister heilig findet er kann sich
sehen lassen ich finde das eine
anständige haushalt ich freue mich auf
die weiteren beratungen wir werden ihn
besser machen hier im parlament und zwar
gemeinsam mit fdp als bündnis 90/die
grünen und als sozialdemokratische
partei vielen dank
sagte andreas ott skier für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und sie sehen dass
verehrte zuschauer in der vorschau
während der bundestag hier noch in den
haushaltsberatungen steckt werfen wir
auch wenn es soweit ist ein blick nach
brüssel der am rande des eu gipfels
wollen us-präsident beiden und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
an energie vertrag unterzeichnen das ist
ein statement angekündigt
sehr geehrter herr minister weil meine
damen und herren die ampel ist mit
großen versprechungen angetreten zur
finanzierung der hehren ziele von
klimarettung gleichstellung und
migrationspolitik sollten sämtliche
ausgaben auf den prüfstand von
priorisierung waren koalitionsvertrag
die rede was damit gemeint ist das sehen
wir heute mehr geld fürs klima weniger
für die menschen schon im ersten entwurf
des bundeshaushaltes sollte am etat für
arbeit und soziales gespart werden und
nun im vorliegenden zweiten entwurf wird
noch weiter gekürzt konkret heißt das
2,8 milliarden weniger will der staat
für sozialleistungen ausgeben davon
alleine 1,8 milliarden weniger folge
zwei empfänger ich frage mich was sie zu
diesem optimismus verleitet dass wir in
zukunft weniger bedarf an sozialen
hilfen haben werden zwei jahre corona
misswirtschaft hat schon heute viele
betriebe und wirtschaftliche existenzen
gekostet viele hängen am tropf des
kurzarbeitergeldes nun kommt der krieg
in der ukraine dazu schon nach einem
monat sehen wir welch verheerende
auswirkungen die engpässe bei benzin und
energie auf liefer und produktionsketten
haben die ersten speditionen haben
bereits aufgegeben viele betriebe werden
das nicht überleben wir alle wissen die
rezession wird kommen und der bedarf an
sozialleistungen wird steigen nicht
sinken das bestätigt auch das ifo
institut das mit weniger wachstum
rechnet und hohen inflationsraten zudem
mit einer deutlichen zunahme von
kurzarbeit wie solide ist eine
haushaltsplanung die das nicht
berücksichtigt
finanzminister lindner hat ja
angekündigt wegen der ukraine krise
einen ergänzungs haushalt einzubringen
werden wir dann sicher eine erhöhung
dieser haushaltsposition wiederfinden
aber das ist dann doch augenwischerei in
diesem haushaltsentwurf zu sparen in der
gewissheit die fehlenden gelder an
anderer stelle wieder einzubringen der
bundesrechnungshof sagt der
bundeshaushalt muss muss robust
resilient und nachhaltig gestaltet
werden man könnte ergänzen auch mit
ehrlichkeit im aktuellen entwurf wird
der bundesagentur für arbeit ein
darlehen in höhe von einer milliarde
euro eingeräumt im ersten entwurf war
nur von einem zuschuss die rede aber wir
müssen doch schon heute das wird nicht
reichen denn die bea hat bekanntlich
keine rücklagen mehr und wir werden in
zukunft mit mehr staat mit weniger
kurzarbeit rechnen müssen wohl gemerkt
dass alles bei möglichst
gleichbleibender beiträgen am ende heißt
dass aus den krediten werden dann doch
zuschüsse das sollte man dann auch so
benennen wesentlich bedenklicher ist
aber folgendes die bundesregierung hat
2018 per gesetz beschlossen in den
jahren 22 bis 25
sonderzahlungen von zunächst 500
millionen euro jährlich an die
allgemeine rentenversicherung als
finanzierungs sockel zu überweisen im
ersten regierungsentwurf der alten
regierung finden wir diese zahlen auch
im aktuellen regierungsentwurf sind sie
verschwunden
die begründung aus der kabinettsvorlage
ist abenteuerlich dort heißt es ich
zitiere laut der aktuellen renten
schätzungen wird die beitragsatz
obergrenze nach § 287 absatz 1 sgb 6 bis
zum jahre 25 nicht überschritten damit
entfällt die notwendigkeit der
sonderzahlungen des bundes an die
allgemeine rentenversicherung merck 287
ps gb 6 um das jetzt auch gesetzlich zu
stürzen wurde im referentenentwurf von
mittwoch dann mal eben der § 287
aufgehoben also ein generelles wegfallen
des zuschusses ab 23 und im
bundeshaushalts gesetz der juice
zuschuss für 22 gestrichen so schnell
geht das wenn wille und geld nicht da
sind dass es keine zukunftsorientierte
rentenpolitik das ist politik nach
kassenlage wie in einer banane publik
herr minister heil sie haben vor drei
jahren gesagt die rente ist ein
kernversprechen des sozialstaates aber
was ist aus diesem versprechen geworden
keine einigung der ampel auf eine
rentenreform
kein sparen für die zu erwartende
rentenlücke ab 2025 das ist keine
vorausschauende planung sie fahren auf
sicht der für neue maßnahmen die im
koalitionsvertrag angekündigt waren
finden sich in diesem entwurf überhaupt
nicht andere wichtige maßnahmen wurden
gekürzt beispielsweise beim form zur
abmeldung zu wurden härtefällen in der
rentenüberleitung nach vielen jahren des
wartens fanden sich im ersten entwurf
der alten regierung endlich eine
milliarde euro zum aufbau dieses forums
im zweiten entwurf wurde der betrag auf
500 millionen euro gekürzt diese 500
millionen euro sind ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein und werden nicht einmal
ansatzweise ausreichend
beispielsweise beim vorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag die rentenversicherung
mit einem kapitalstock von zehn
milliarden euro auszustatten darauf
warten wir alle schritte werden wir alle
noch lange warten müssen wer nicht
einmal 500 millionen
zugesagte zahlungen an die
rentenversicherung geleistet werden
können insgesamt ist der haushalt zu
diesen einzelplan enttäuschen ich stelle
fest die kürzungsvorgaben sind zu
rigoros und die prioritäten der
regierung falsch ich habe deshalb wenig
hoffnung dass hier in den
haushaltsberatungen noch entscheidend
nachgebessert werden kann ich bedanke
mich
ulrike schicke ziehe sich war das für
die fw fraktion
sie sitzt im haushaltsausschuss
heute nachmittag wird er dann
wurf des bundeshaushaltes mit den
einzelplänen dann in den
haushaltsausschuss federführend zur
weiteren beratung
überwiesen
deswegen hier die haushälter natürlich
auch in der aussprache besonders gefragt
jetzt claudia raffelhüschen haushälterin
für die fdp
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
heute geht es um den größten etat im
bundeshaushalt den einzelplan elf also
um arbeit und soziales kein einzelplan
ist so relevanz für fiskalische
nachhaltigkeit
und generationengerechtigkeit die mir
persönlich am herzen liegt der
einzelplan 11 ist für das laufende jahr
in ein haushalte eingebettet der
zwischen der krone pandemie und der
ukraine krieg kräftig durchgeschüttelt
worden ist ich rede von einem haushalt
der zu mehr als der hälfte aus
sozialausgaben einschließlich der
zuweisung an die rentenkasse besteht ein
drittel unserer gesamten wertschöpfung
wird also umverteilt und damit liegen
wir weltweit mit an der spitze wie soll
ich sagen glücklicherweise verfügen über
die höchste steuerquote am
bruttoinlandsprodukt in unserer
geschichte mehr geld wurde den menschen
hierzulande noch nie über steuern und
beiträge entzogen und trotz relativ zur
wirtschaftsleistung
höchsten steuereinnahmen sind wir in
dieser sondersituation leider gezwungen
eine neue
hohe neuverschuldung einzugehen dabei
darf es auf dauer natürlich nicht
bleiben zumal
zumal die ganze last der schulden
unserer zumal wir die ganze last der
schulden unseren kindern aufbürden
lassen sie uns also gemeinsam so schnell
wie möglich in einer nachhaltigen
haushaltspolitik arbeiten denn wir
können nicht deutlich mehr in
verteidigung infrastruktur und
energiewende investieren ohne in allen
haushaltstiteln die budget ansätze so zu
gestalten dass wir mit weniger mitteln
bessere ergebnisse erzielen
auch und gerade der reid-plan 11 ist
weiterhin geprägt von großen
herausforderungen die durch die kapruner
pandemie ausgelöst wurden der staat hat
in den vergangenen monaten an wichtigen
stellschrauben gedreht um bürgerinnen
und bürger unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer zu entlasten das war wichtig
das war richtig und trotzdem dürfen all
diese sonderregeln nicht zu automatismen
werden denn was für corona nicht klug
war das wird durch die veränderte lage
nicht intelligenter
beispielsweise war der vereinfachte
zugang zum kurzarbeitergeld während der
krise essentiell hat viele unternehmen
vor der insolvenz bewahrt und
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern ein
adäquates einkommen gesichert
insbesondere in zeiten der
wirtschaftlichen erholung müssen wir
aber jetzt den sinn und zweck solcher
sonderregelung evaluieren die gute
nachricht zuletzt entwickelte sich der
arbeitsmarkt wieder
erfolgsversprechend die arbeitslosigkeit
und unterbeschäftigung sind im vergleich
zu den vergangenen monat die nachfrage
ist mitarbeiter bewegt sich weiterhin
auf hohem niveau nichtsdestotrotz wirken
sich lieferengpässe und die großen
unsicherheiten durch den russischen
angriff auf die ukraine mit noch nicht
absehbaren folgen auf unseren
arbeitsmarkt und die sozialpolitik aus
deutschland hat es in den vergangenen
jahren leider versäumt eine geregelte
einwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt zu
ermöglichen aus arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer sicht brauchen wir
diese fachkräfte um die rente die mit
über 100 millionen euro pro jahr durch
den bund bezuschusst zu stabilisieren
und das ist sozialsystem zu entlasten
eigentlich ist dies seit dem pillenknick
hinlänglich bekannt dazu seit
jahrzehnten wurde aber erfolgreich
ignoriert jetzt geht es hier
nachzubessern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der punkt investiert in den sozialstaat
und dieser wächst enorm lassen wir uns
aber nicht täuschen denn so schön der
steigende etat auch klingt und so viel
gutes mit dem geld bewirkt werden soll
umso anfälliger wird das gesamtsystem
wenn wir nicht strukturell nachbessern
insbesondere in den großen blöcken
arbeitsmarkt und rente besteht
reformbedarf das im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbarte bürgergeld wird erste
bürokratische entlastung für bürger und
auch die verwaltung bringen den
kolleginnen
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der cdu/csu frage nein
den allerbesten reformbedarf gibt es
allerdings bei der rente bevor
2025 die sogenannte doppelte halten ja
ausläuft brauchen wir kluge lösung um da
wären wir wieder bei meinen kindern und
den zukünftigen generationen auch ihnen
eine angemessene zukunft zu sichern
denn das wurde seit jahren versprochen
und das höchste gut eines politischen
lebens ist doch die glaubwürdigkeit
vielen dank
claudia raffelhüschen war das für die
fdp fraktion
die rente ist eine dauerbaustelle
reform der riester rente ist nötig und
die fdp hatte das projekt aktien rente
ja in den koalitionsvertrag sozusagen
hineinverhandelt
die davon ist aber in diesem haushalt
noch nichts zu sehen
heute morgen muss ich meine rede mit der
forderung beginnen putin muss die
russische armee aus der ukraine abziehen
den krieg bällen die menschen in der
ukraine und überall in der welt haben
das recht in frieden zu leben
und
ich finde es falsch dass in dieser
situation die ausgaben für arbeit und
soziales gekürzt werden der rüstungsetat
wird erhöht das hat allerdings nichts
mit dem krieg in der ukraine zu tun das
war lange vorbereitet meine damen und
herren die bundesregierung geht mit
diesem haushaltsentwurf für den
einzelplan elf von sinkenden
arbeitslosenzahlen aus aber in
anbetracht einer globalen
wirtschaftskrise in anbetracht von
kriegen und ihren folgen ist das doch
mehr als fraglich hier muss also
vorgesorgt werden und nicht gestrichen
meine damen und herren
kreis explosion bei energie und
lebensmitteln bedrohen viele menschen
besonders die die wenig geld haben
deshalb fordern wir den mindestlohn
nicht erst zum ersten oktober 2022 auf
12 euro zu erhöhen sondern bereits zum
ersten mal die menschen brauchen das
geld bekommt
ich weiß die erhöhung des mindestlohnes
ist für die fdp kein thema sie fühlt
sich er zuständig für die verwaltung der
vermögen der superreichen
doch von spd und grünen erwarte ich dass
sie ein zeichen setzen zwölf euro pro
stunde am tag der arbeit das wäre ein
gutes zeichen
generation satz haben sie um ganze drei
euro angehoben es ist beschämend wie sie
mit den arbeitslosen umgehen für
stromkosten bekommen aktuell arbeitslose
eine pauschale von 36 euro pro monat
aber derzeit zeigt man fast das doppelte
weil man einen neuvertrag beim
günstigsten anbieter abschließen meine
damen und herren der paritätische
wohlfahrtsverband fordert einen
hartz-iv-satz von 678 euro pro monat
diese forderung unterstützen die
renten steigen im augenblick doch von
der erhöhung wird nicht viel übrig
bleiben die inflation frisst die
rentenerhöhung auf und wir wiederholen
unsere forderung die ost renten müssen
endlich angepasst werden das betrifft
nicht nur die heutigen rentner sondern
auch künftige und das ist nötig
mai nahmen die rente muss auch ein thema
für die jugend werden die
bundesregierung will die rente den
risiken des kapitalmarktes aussetzen
aber wir wollen keine pensionsfonds die
im krieg kohle und atomkraft investieren
generationengerechtigkeit heißt auch
dass die heutige jugend im alter eine
gute und saubere rente halten kann
kindern
gesehen dass die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken ja und
zur rente ganz abgesehen von
dem nächsten
sozusagen an reformbemühungen ansteht
hat die bundesregierung in der letzten
woche mitgeteilt hat die renten zum
ersten juli im westen um gut 5 prozent
im osten um gut sechs prozent steigen
die jährliche rentenanpassung seit
dienstag beschäftigen wir uns hier im
parlament mit dem haushaltsentwurf in
all seinen facetten
wir haben viele reden gehört reden über
einen haushalt in herausfordernden
zeiten doch eins kam mir oft und sehr
selten zu tage
in diese reden habe ich vermisst dass
angesichts der aktuellen lage und
vielfältigen herausforderungen denen wir
uns stellen müssen für besonders wichtig
ja entscheidend achte das übernehmen von
verantwortung
verantwortung für kommendes
verantwortung dafür in zeiten wie diesen
einen haushalt aufzustellen der gerecht
und gleichermaßen auskömmlich ist denn
wir stehen vor einer entscheidenden
zeitenwende sicherheits und
energiepolitisch wirtschaftlich wie auch
gesellschaftlich es sozial gerecht zu
gestalten alle mitzunehmen das muss doch
unser anspruch sein
jetzt ist nicht die zeit für
rückwärtsgewandte schuldzuweisung und
drohgebärden jetzt ist zeit für kluge
entscheidung für konstruktive
zusammenarbeit dass es zeit für
fraktionsübergreifend dabei jetzt ist
zeit dafür die zeitenwende finanziell
und sozial sicher zu gestalten
und jetzt ist zeit dafür verantwortung
zu übernehmen und genau dafür steht die
ampel koalition mit unserem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz an ihrer
spitze
im einzelplan 11 das sind ausgaben von
über 160 milliarden euro vorgesehen 160
milliarden euro für unseren sozialstaat
160 milliarden euro für die
existenzielle sicherheit eines jeden
einzelnen und 160 milliarden euro für
den sozialen frieden in deutschland
eine globalisierte sich schnell
ändernden arbeitswelt sich zusätzlich
dem demografischen wandel und der
digitalisierung zu stellen hat verlangt
immer wieder nach neuen antworten und
dachten wir zu anfang die bewältigung
der kurve 19 pandemie wäre unsere größte
herausforderung in diesen zeiten weit
gefehlt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
putin führt einen verabscheuungswürdigen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine und hat
sich schuldig gemacht dass millionen von
ukrainerin aus ihrer heimat flüchten
müssen sie flüchten denn ihre
nachbarländer aber auch zu tausenden
nach deutschland es liegt doch jetzt in
unserer verantwortung auch diesen
menschen in deutschland sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und über den moment hinaus
gedacht in die chance für einen
neuanfang zu bieten wir gehen davon aus
dass viele der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer hier in deutschland arbeiten
wollen es sind überwiegend frauen die zu
uns kommen gut ausgebildet mit
fachschulabschluss in und um
sicherzustellen dass sie eben nicht auf
helfertätigkeiten ausweichen müssen
sondern ihre ausbildung entsprechend
eingesetzt werden können es die
berufsbezogene deutsch sprach forderung
zwingend notwendig
und bereits sie war dass der golfsport
und nicht hinlänglich finanziert sein
wird und darum müssen wir gewährleisten
dass die entsprechenden mittel zur
verfügung gestellt werden
grundlage des entwurfs war von großen
die eine erholung des arbeitsmarktes
nach profit 19 voraussagten nun der
krieg lässt unsere lieferketten stocken
energiepreise in die höhe schnellen und
wieder sind arbeitsplätze in gefahr und
darum ist es für unsere volkswirtschaft
existenziell dass wir das
kurzarbeitergeld weiter als stabile
brücke vorhalten es ist das wirksamste
mittel die menschen in arbeit zu halten
und entlassungen vorzubeugen wir haben
mit einem ausgewogenen einzelplan
sicherzustellen dass das bfs weiter so
sicher und zuverlässig sein zahlreichen
aufgaben nachgehen kann und dazu gehört
dass mittels einer gezielten
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik
entsprechend zu reagieren aber auch im
besonderen vorausschauend agieren zu
können ziel dabei ist es dass so viele
menschen wie möglich eine
erwerbstätigkeit nachgehen können wir
finanzieren arbeit statt
arbeitslosigkeit wir wollen
mitbestimmung das pack und sicherheit
und das gilt selbstverständlich auch für
die menschen die neu zu uns kommen sie
alle brauchen zur teilhabe eine
perspektive eine verlässliche
unterstützung und dafür müssen wir
entsprechende beratungsangebote ausbauen
der sozialstaat muss vor lebensrisiken
schützen und verlässlich bleiben und
damit der sozialstaat leistungsfähig und
verlässlich bleibt müssen wir die
nötigen mittel klug und nachhaltig
einsetzen einsparen um des sparens
willen wäre fatal und verantwortungslos
wir als essen er stellt ganz klar die
menschen in den metropolen der sache das
was sie für eine gute arbeit und eine
auskömmliche soziale sicherung in
verschiedenen phasen des lebens
benötigen stellen wir ihn zur verfügung
die bundesagentur für arbeit ist das
zentrale organ für den sozialen
arbeitsmarkt in zeiten der pandemie hat
die bundesagentur mit dem instrument der
kurzarbeit eine brücke gebaut so dass
arbeitsplätze erhalten werden konnten
und die volkswirtschaft nicht größeren
schaden genommen hat nun für putin krieg
und die aktuellsten prognosen zeigen
heute das eine verdoppelung der
ursprünglich erwarteten bezieherinnen
von kurzarbeitergeld mehr als
wahrscheinlich ist eine verdopplung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das im
vorliegenden entwurf des einzelplan 11
angedachte darlehen für die
bundesagentur für arbeit ist nicht das
geeignete mittel dabei es führt in gänze
zu einer schwächung der handlungs
wirksamkeit wir benötigen jetzt eine
starke agentur die jederzeit in der lage
ist angemessen und flexibel auf die sich
abzeichnenden herausforderungen zu
reagieren
eine agentur ohne schulden
helmut schmidt sagte in der krise zeigt
sich der charakter und wir stehen für
den sozialen zusammenhalt und ein
solidarisches miteinander
diese aufgabe steht im mittelpunkt
dieses haushalts das ist unsere
verantwortung das ist sicherheit im
wandel ich freue mich auf erfolgreiche
beratungen vielen dank und glückauf
sagt gabriele michel für die
spd-fraktion sitz im ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales
bevor ich dem nächsten redner aufrufe
noch mal einen hinweis an die kollegin
frau von storch sie hatten vorhin
die ganze zeit wieder die maske leider
unter der nase ich würde sie bitten auch
wenn es schwer fällt das handy manchmal
mit maske zu entsperren
weil wir gestern im ältestenrat auch
nochmal ausführlich darüber gesprochen
haben noch haben wir hier die masken
pflicht und ich bitte sie die maske
richtig auch sie jetzt aber sie haben
während ich habe drei minuten mindestens
ich habe
das kann ich nicht während einer rede
will ich die rede nicht unterbrechen
deswegen tue ich das jetzt sonst hätte
ich das sicherlich sofort gemacht aber
ich will und möchte auch die rednerinnen
und redner nicht immer deswegen
unterbrechen es ist nur noch mal ein
zarter hinweis ich bitte einfach nur
darum
dass wir uns alle daran halten so lange
es diese masken pflicht noch gibt hier
im saal vielen dank
der nächste redner ist jetzt für die cdu
csu fraktion peter
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir über
den haushalt arbeit und soziales reden
können wir zu beginn drei dinge
feststellen erstens unsere deutsche
wirtschaft und der arbeitsmarkt sind
stabil zweitens unser sozialstaat
funktioniert und ist leistungsfähig und
drittens es muss sich aber einiges
ändern dass das auch in zukunft so
bleibt
auch viele drei punkte möchte ich meiner
rede kurz eingehen erstens das thema
arbeitsmarkt und wirtschaft sie wurde
angehalten und so immer vor was in 16
jahren regierungsverantwortung alles
schief gelaufen sein soll meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren werden wir
über den haushalt arbeit und soziales
sprechen dann zeigen wir ihnen das
paradebeispiel verantwortungsvolle
politik funktioniert andauern der
beschäftigungszuwachs 16 jahre lang 2009
40 9 millionen
erwerbstätige 2009/10 45,3 millionen
erwerbstätige zahl der arbeitslosen
halbiert seit 2005 ich denke das ist
eine bilanz die sie meine damen und
herren erst mal nachmachen müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
arbeitsmarkt politik funktioniert vor
allem durch eine aktivierende
arbeitsmarktpolitik
deshalb kann man nur mit dem kopf
schütteln wenn eine ihrer ersten
maßnahmen des aussetzen der sanktionen
in der grundsicherung für arbeitsuchende
es treten sie reden sie ihr kollege
burkhardt mal mit der bundesagentur für
arbeit reden sie mit den jobcentern vor
ort vielleicht sollten sie mal läuft
auch im wahlkreis unterwegs sein dann
merken sie das fordern und fördern für
die menschen ein ganz wesentlicher punkt
verantwortungsvolle
arbeitsmarktpolitik bedeutet vor allem
in krisenzeiten starke zeichen zu setzen
wir haben das in unserer
regierungsverantwortung getan zwei große
rezessionen wir haben gemeinsam mit den
kollegen der spd starke antworten
gegeben die fdp war sogar mit dabei beim
thema kurzarbeitergeld in der
finanzkrise 2008 2009 1,4 millionen in
der finanzkrise 6 millionen menschen im
höhepunkt der coop 19 pandemie waren in
kurzarbeit und ich denke dass auch so
ein signal gesetzt wird wie
verantwortungsvolle politik gemacht wird
und der mann heute auf sich als liebe
kollegen der ampel
regierungshandeln wäre gefragt in einer
großen weiteren krise von der wir in
europa stehen und auf der welt die
ukraine krise steigende energiepreise
hohe inflation kraftvolles handeln der
ampelkoalition fehlanzeige liebe
kollegen ende februar erstes
entlastungspaket angekündigt 13
milliarden euro nicht mal einen monat
später braucht es ist zweiter
entlastungspaket weil nicht aus einem
guss
nicht überlegt nicht nachgedacht meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren so
funktioniert verantwortungsvolle politik
nicht und wenn man dann genauer schaut
ist es keine
sozialpolitik aus einem guss sondern
herr heil auch wenn es anders
dargestellt haben sozialpolitik mit
gießkanne und dass meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ist nicht die antwort
die wir in dieser zeit brauchen das
kritisieren alle sozialverbände
angefangen vom vdk die sagen die
rentnerinnen und rentner wurden
vergessen von der diakonie vom
bayerischen caritasverband die sagen
dass das alles sozial nicht ausgewogen
ist und dass meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ist auch denke ich auftrag
für simon klein bisschen genauer zu
schauen vor allem wenn man immer sehr
großes thema respekt in den letzten
wochen und monaten gespielt hat zu und
einen funktionierenden sozialstaat
gehört auch respekt vor leistung und
dass meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ist in einer zeit wie diesen und
bei den entlastungs paket ebenfalls
wichtig weil meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren das geld das wir hier heute
ausgeben muss auch irgendjemand
erwirtschaften und verdienen deswegen
aber wir wissen dass sie wahrscheinlich
nicht weil ein entlastungspaket und kein
einziges mal entlastungen für die
wirtschaft auftauchen dort wo
arbeitsplätze entstehen gesichert werden
gerade im energieintensiven bereich um
sie total vergessen deswegen bin ich
ganz fest der überzeugung dass das
nächste
entlastungspaket drei wahrscheinlich
auch ganz schnell folgen werden muss
dass wir hier schwerere folgen und einen
schweren schaden für unser land auch
vermeiden können meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der fortschritts
koalition fortschritt schaut anders aus
für uns ist wichtig gerade in dieser
zeit dass wir auch weichen neu stellen
dass wir darüber nachdenken wie
funktioniert der arbeitsmarkt der
zukunft wie funktioniert der sozialstaat
und die sozialsysteme der zukunft dass
sie auch weiterhin leistungsfähig sind
wenn man genauer in den haushalt schaut
wird deutlich dass sie keine neuen
impulse setzen beispielsweise beim
haushaltstitel arbeitswelt im wandel und
fachkräftesicherung unsere wirtschaft
braucht dringend neue impulse
trafen wünschen ataspor in ihrer rede ja
gesagt impulse fehlen aber in diesem
haus holger bei diesem wichtigen thema
in einer wirtschaft die nicht nur
fachkräftemangel mittlerweile hat
sondern auch arbeitskräftemangel und
auch beim thema soziale sicherheit
müssen wir die weichen stellen bei der
rente müssen wir endlich wegkommen von
den grundsatzdebatten und antworten
finden
antworten antworten herr kollege rose
waren die wir erarbeitet haben in der
letzten legislaturperiode in einer
großen kommission diese punkte müssen
wir endlich in umsetzung bringen und
dazu haben wir die zusammenarbeit als
union angeboten weil uns wichtig ist ein
system zukunftsfest zu machen auch dass
viele menschen in unserem land vertrauen
seit jahrzehnten und deswegen müssen wir
da auch eine starke antwort finden die
hand ist ausgestreckt und ich glaube
hier müssen wir gemeinsam den menschen
in unserem land eine antwort geben und
die antworten die der politisch
motiviert in vielerlei bereichen sind
merken wir ja bei der fdp die mit zehn
milliarden
fehlen irgendwie in diesem haushalt wir
wissen wenn man kapitalgedecktes system
dann müssen wir schnell anfangen nun mal
gespannt wie lange wir brauchen bis man
das system dann auch einführen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
sozialpolitik arbeitsmarktpolitik
braucht starke impulse den nächsten
jahren wir als union sind dabei diese
impulse zu setzen herzlichen dank für
die
sagt ihr peter aumer für die
unionsfraktionen in
richtung der großen koalition
nächster redner für die fraktion bilden
oder 90 mal sehen was bündnis 90 die
grünen hier in person von frank
bsirske
zum einzelplan sagen
ihnen auch mal möchte ich einfach mal
einblick in die dokumente empfehlen der
entlastungspaket manchmal verschaffte
lektüre echten erkenntnisgewinne
die ökologische transformation
mit einem mehr an sozialer sicherheit
verbinden ist ein zentrales anliegen
grüner politik
dafür haben wir in der
koalitionsvereinbarung wichtige akzente
gesetzt für ein bürgergeld dass das
system überwindet für eine
kindergrundsicherung die kinderarmut in
unserem land entgegenwirkt und für eine
arbeitsmarktpolitik die den
beschäftigten perspektiven eröffnet das
wollen wir in den kommenden monaten
weiter konkretisieren und das hat aber
auch schon in diesem haushaltsentwurf
seinen niederschlag gefunden ich nenne
beispielhaft den kinder sofort zuschlag
die aufstockung der weiterbildungs
mittel für das programm arbeitswelt im
wandel die verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeldes oder auch die
fortführung des sozialdienstleister
einsatz gesetzes
teil
freilich gibt es punkte wo in den
beratungen zum vorgelegten entwurf nach
zu arbeiten sein wird für das programm
barrierefreiheit müssen zusätzlich
mittel in die finanzplanung eingestellt
werden und auch der eingliederungs titel
für den sozialen arbeitsmarkt wird
deutlich angehoben werden müssen der
soziale arbeitsmarkt hat sich bewährt
eine mittelkürzung verbietet sich schon
deshalb weil die zahl der arbeitsplätze
dort nicht verringern wollen
und ab ersten zehn
die anhebung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns den meisten arbeitsplätzen
in diesem bereich zu grunde liegt
benötigt werden mithin mehr mittel und
nicht weniger
damit aber nicht genug
sehen wir uns jetzt doch alle mit den
folgen des russischen angriffskrieges
gegen die ukraine konfrontiert
die wachstumsannahmen brandaktuellen
nach unten korrigiert
produktionsausfälle führen zu einem
erneuten anstieg der anzahl der
kurzarbeitenden die integration
hunderttausender geflüchteter in den
arbeitsmarkt und unsere gesellschaft
stellt uns vor große aufgaben
ob mit einem rückgang der
arbeitslosenzahlen gerechnet werden kann
ist mehr als fraglich und anhaltende
preisanstieg konfrontiert die privaten
haushalte ebenso wie viele unternehmen
mit hohen belastungen
neben der einarbeitung des zweiten
entlastungs paket ist der ampel verlangt
das zwingt eine erweiterung des
haushaltsentwurfs denn im gefolge der
ukraine kriege krisen des ukraine
krieges kommen zusätzliche aufgaben auch
auf die bundesagentur für arbeit zu und
das in einem maße wie es so bis vor
kurzem überhaupt nicht absehbar war
sprachkurse das war bereits angesprochen
werden für die integration der
geflüchteten in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt erfolgskritisch dafür
müssen zusätzlich mittel bereitgestellt
werden
die wünschenswerte überführung der
gefürchteten aus dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz in das sgb 2
wird nicht unerhebliche mittel erfordern
das gleiche gilt für die einbeziehung
der leiharbeit in das verlängerte
kurzarbeitergeld und sie zukommen kann
noch eine rückerstattung von
sozialversicherungsabgaben an die
unternehmen all das
macht es erforderlich auch weiterhin
darlehens beträge an die bh in einen
zuschuss umzuwandeln
keine frage die folgen des ukraine
krieges verlangt nach einer stärkung des
sozialen zusammenhalts in unserem land
dabei stellen sich von neuem auf fragen
der verteilungsgerechtigkeit
in dieser woche ist von verschiedenen
rednerinnen und rednern wiederholt
empörung geäußert worden mit blick auf
das vorgehen der mineralölkonzerne und
das sehr zu recht das sind
kriegsgewinnler
profiteure des krieges konzerne die aus
der not der menschen in austin wirkungen
des krieges extra profite schlagen und
ich frage sie wollen wir die
extraprofite sicherheit konzerne
wirklich unter welpenschutz stellen und
als sakrosankt hinnehmen wollen wir das
wirklich
wollen wir das wirklich einer situation
wir starten milliarden kredite aufnehmen
um den folgen dieses krieges zu begegnen
oder sollten wir nicht klima das tun was
in der vergangenheit staaten wie die usa
großbritannien frankreich kanada aus
anderen kriegs und krisenzeiten immer
wieder getan haben und was jetzt in
dieser woche auch die regierung trage in
italien herr angekündigt hat nämlich
mindestens einen teil dieser
extraprofite mittels einer über gewinn
steuer zugunsten allgemeinheit
abzuschöpfen
abgeordnete
wir sprechen in dieser woche über unsere
finanzplanung und den nächsten
bundeshaushalt da den blick zu weiten
macht sinn es wäre ein signal zugunsten
eines mehr an sozialer gerechtigkeit und
für eine faire verteilung der lasten
frank bsirske war das für bis 90 die
grünen die lange jahre war er
vorsitzender der gewerkschaft verdi seit
2000 21 ja hier im bundestag nicht
gerade als er beispielsweise auch
überall ein rechter die abschöpfung
möglicher gewinne beim mineralölkonzern
angesprochen hat da hat der
koalitionspartner in den reihen der fdp
nicht gerade begeistert geklatscht hier
muss man sie gar nicht geklatscht igen
und kollegen jetzt reden wir doch
endlich mal über den elefant im raum und
das ist die inflation
6% erwartet 7 prozent bei den
lebensmitteln 20,8 prozent bei der
energie 30 prozent bei den kraftstoffen
dass das noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange meine damen und herren die
inflation ist die soziale frage weil sie
uns direkt in die rezession und in
verlust des wohlstand zu führen und
meine damen und herren
das ist ihre inflation das ist ihre
verantwortung das ist kein ferner putin
und kein ferner konzern habe sie es geht
sondern das ist die europäische
zentralbank die geld druckt ohne ende
und es sind ihre hohe renten steuern mit
denen sie versuchen die leute zu
erziehen zu einem gewissen verhalten sie
treiben doch die preise mit ihrer co2
steuer mit ihren energie steuern und
ihrer völlig falschen politik es ist
ehre inflation
und das haben sie uns
lacht als er forderte den atomausstieg
zurückzunehmen um bezahlbare energie zu
haben oder die energie steuern zu senken
illegale migranten zurückzuweisen damit
der wohnraum nicht exorbitant teuer wird
keinen locker zu machen damit die
wirtschaft entsprechend mittel hat oder
eben aus dem euro auszusteigen weil die
ezb geld druckt und politik gegen den
bürger macht meine damen und herren die
geldmenge hat sich seit einführung des
euro fast verdreifacht fragen sie mal
die leute ob sie jetzt drei mal so viel
verdienen
dreimal so viel bezahlen tun sie ganz
sicher und da vergeht ihnen das lachen
wenn sie nicht mehr wissen wie sie für
ihre kinder die kleidung kaufen sollen
wie sie ihre miete bezahlen soll wie sie
noch heizen sollen und was kriegen die
leute dafür sie kriegen hohn und spott
unter anderem von cdu minister hauk der
forderte 15 grad reichen aus in einer
wohnung
werte mitglieder der regierung ist jetzt
in ihrer verantwortung zu handeln
aber dieser verantwortung und wir gehen
ganz schnell nach brüssel
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen was
wir eigentlich erwartet haben und
bei den renten dann wissen sie noch
recht nicht recht ob sie beziehen wollen
oder nicht vielleicht reichen daher
pullover und eine warme decke meine
damen und herren die afg hat ihnen schon
vor monaten vorschläge unterbreitet wie
diese härten abzumildern sind neben dem
bestehen natürlich auf
geldwertstabilität bei der währung geht
es darum den steuerlichen
grundfreibetrag nicht nur um 3 100 euro
sondern und knapp 3000 euro zu erhöhen
denn selbstverständlich müssen wir noch
das existenzminimum steuerfrei stellen
prozent denn in diesem land die
regelsätze hartz iv grundsicherung
müssen natürlich angepasst werden der
sparerpauschbetrag sollte erhöht werden
und auch die entfernungspauschale
sollten wir realistisch gestalten mit 38
cent pro kilometer aber das alles machen
sie nicht sie halten fest an co2 steuern
je g und lagergebäude energie gesetz all
das müsste ausgesetzt werden auch die
mehrwertsteuer auf energie treibstoffe
und lebensmittel für eine zeit um eben
diese folgt der inflation abzumildern
aber nichts davon findet sich im
haushaltsentwurf sie sparen
ausgerechnet bei der integration
schwerbehinderter in den arbeitsmarkt da
gehen sie zurück von 606 auf 519
millionen das ist eine schande für sich
damit sie eineinhalb millionen haben für
die g7 präsidentschaft eineinhalb
millionen für einen freiwilligen beitrag
für die internationale
arbeitsorganisation
für die deutsch sprach förderung und
sieben millionen für ein ganz neues
programm unsere arbeit unsere vielfalt
initiative für betriebliche demokratie
kompetenz da lernt vermutlich dann der
integrationswillige migranten dass die
afg doof und freude ist future
antirassistisch sein
wer sie könnte irgendwo der fdp herr
fricke hat uns ja aufgefordert kosten zu
nennen wo wir sparen können einsparungen
vornehmen dazu sind ja auch da und ich
gebe ihnen mein tipp das sind posten wo
man ausgaben hat aber keine einnahmen
zum beispiel die ganzen europäischen
fonds esm gft habt dann mitunter gehen
ganz schnell nach brüssel zum toben und
ursula von der leyen damit an dass man
nichts sinnlos verschleudert meine damen
und herren
eine zahl gibt mir denn auch noch rätsel
auf in diesem haushalt und das ist
tatsächlich wie sie dazu kommen dass bei
all diesen inflationseffekte armut
arbeitslosigkeit bei ihren cupid lockt
das lieferketten probleme ukraine
millionen kriegsflüchtlinge dass sie
dazu kommen dass sie den einsatz für die
grundsicherung senken von 45 milliarden
auf 40 und für die kosten von unterkunft
und heizung und ich habe mir dann
gedacht haben sie sich verrechnen kann
eigentlich nicht sein haben sie uns
verladen und bringt das alles aus dem
nachtragshaushalt das wird ziemlich
wenig liebe fdp von einer service
regiert was sich doch von ihnen erwartet
und dann ist es mir wie schuppen von den
augen gefallen ist kann ja nur dass sein
sicherlich wird nancy faeser endlich mal
die hunderttausenden illegalen migranten
abschieben die bei uns affen dann
stimmen auch die zahlen in der
grundsicherung wieder und ich danke
ihnen werte kollegen der spd und der
grünen dass sie diesen wichtigen schritt
für die bundesrepublik deutschland mit
uns zusammen gehen werden ich freue mich
auf die parlamentarische begleitung
dieses wichtigen schritt des prozesses
haben sie herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
pascal kober
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der angriff
putins auf die ukraine gehen auch nicht
spurlos am politikbereich arbeitsmarkt
und sozialpolitik vorbei liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
erschütternd mit welcher ruchlosigkeit
mit welcher brutalität
wladimir putin die menschen in der
ukraine
aus ihrer sozialen existenz regelrecht
in die flucht hinauskommt und so werden
die kommenden wochen und monate auch im
bereich arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik
wesentlich davon geprägt sein wie wir
die wehrhaftigkeit unser freiheitlich
demokratie wie wir die mehrheiten in
wehrhaftigkeit eines völkerrechtlich
gebundenen staates einer völkerrechtlich
gebundenen welt auch sozialpolitisch mit
unterstützen damit am ende wo die nicht
recht bekommen ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen
und zugleich müssen wir mit denken auch
heute schon dass möglicherweise die
menschen die jetzt zu uns kommen über
einen längeren zeitraum bei uns schutz
brauchen und da werden wir dafür sorgen
dass die lebenshaltungskosten
gewährleistet sind das pflege und
betreuung gewährleistet ist für die
menschen die zu uns kommen und der bald
gebrauchen brauchen und vor allen dingen
müssen wir aber auch den arbeitstag
zugang nicht so ermöglichen dass die
menschen möglichst nicht unterhalb ihrer
qualifikation
sondern qualifiziert in unserem
arbeitsmarkt zugang finden
die kollegen belegen die hochnäsigkeit
des russischen präsidenten mag noch so
groß sein aber ich glaube ich spreche
für alle demokratischen fraktionen in
ihrem haus die solidarität unseres
sozialstaates wird stärker sein und
darauf können sich die menschen
verlassen
und dabei ist uns allen natürlich
bewusst dass die auswirkungen des
krieges in der ukraine auch
wirtschaftlicher unsicherheit zu uns
bringen die steigenden energiekosten
möglicherweise auch eines tages
ausfallen der
energielieferungen abbrechenden
lieferketten allgemein steigende preise
werden ihre auswirkungen auf unseren
arbeitsmarkt haben aber auch wenn vieles
schwerer werden wird eine zusage machen
wir den menschen in unserem land wir
werden trotz aller schwierigkeiten die
ideen unseres sitzt ist unseres
koalitionsvertrages in der arbeitsmarkt
und sozialpolitik umsätzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dabei ist uns als fdp insbesondere
zweierlei richtig das ist die
generationengerechtigkeit auf der einen
seite und das ist die
chancengerechtigkeit auf der anderen
seite und generationengerechtigkeit
bedeutet dass wir zb im bereich der
rentenpolitik nicht nur bis zum ende
dieser legislaturperiode denken sondern
dass wir in generationen denken und das
will das rentensystem auf nachhaltige
weise reformieren und für die zukunft
aufstellen und dazu gehört natürlich die
aktien rente dazu gehört ein
kapitalgedeckter baustein zur
stabilisierung der rentenversicherung
dazu gehört aber auch die ausweitung der
betrieblichen altersvorsorge und die
flexibilisierung der privaten
altersvorsorge und auch im bereich der
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit werden wir neue
wege gehen den einstieg und den
wiedereinstieg in arbeit in den weg in
ein selbstbestimmtes leben werden wir
eben in dem wir den menschen die hier
für individuell notwendige bildungs und
ausbildungsangebote machen werden das
ist es was unser anspruch ist die
menschen in die arbeit zu bringen
und das fängt natürlich auch bei den
grundkompetenzen herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lesen schreiben
und rechnen lernen zu dürfen
auch jenseits des schulleiters und auch
wenn man es vielleicht zwei oder drei
mal im leben noch nicht geschafft hat
das ist ein soziales grundrecht das für
jeden in diesem land möglich sein muss
und wir werden den worten kein kind darf
verloren gehen endlich mit
sozialpolitischer substanz begegnen wir
werden diesem versprechen auch wirklich
ein inhalt geben zum beispiel mit dem
digitalen kinder chancen portal in dem
wir die angebote in der bildung und
teilhabe für kinder auch wirklich
erreichbar und unkompliziert umsetzbar
machen werden chancengerechtigkeit wird
in diesem land verbessert werden dafür
steht diese regierungskoalition
und wir werden die kooperation der
jobcenter mit der jugendhilfe ausweiten
damit junge menschen auch schon in
frühen jahren früheren jahren als bisher
beim schulerfolg unterstützt werden
können den schulerfolg ist die
vorausbildung für ausbildungserfolg
ausbildungserfolg sind vielen fällen die
garantie dafür dass
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit verbieten
werden kann und so werden wir die
gedanken des präventiven sozialstaates
mit diesen ganz konkreten maßnahmen
umsetzen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der regierungskoalition ich freue mich
darauf wir haben viel vor wir werden
viel erreichen dieses versprechen geben
wir den menschen in unserem land vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke so seine fesche
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen herr
minister pandemie klimakrise inflation
krieg all drohende wirtschaftskrise
dieser dauer krisen modus verschärft die
soziale ungleichheit im land und
betroffen sind menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen aber auch die mittelschicht
leidet wohl gleichzeitig bekommt
aufrüstung verfassungsrang 100
milliarden euro als sondervermögen für
rüstung berät
menschen im rat sitzen also auch
diejenigen die aufstocken müssen und
rentner in grundsicherung sind in echter
finanzieller not und um armut
wirkungsvoll zu bekämpfen sind aus sicht
der linken mindestens drei
sofortmassnahmen nötig und zwar
dauerhaft und nicht nur als
einmalzahlung eine erhöhung der
regelsätze auf deutlich über 600 euro
eine mindestrente von 1200 euro ist
unter die auffanglinie
in summe wurde das ungefähr 30
milliarden euro kosten nicht mal ein
drittel des über nacht bereitgestellten
sondervermögens und der berater des
finanzministers lars feld der hat
bereits am dienstag gesagt genau das was
sie aufgeschlossen haben herr minister
er hat angekündigt dass zugunsten der
militärischen aufrüstung im sozialen
gespart werden muss und letztlich sieht
man es ja auch schon an der einen oder
anderen stelle die sonderzahlungen des
bundes in die rentenkasse die werden in
diesem jahr nicht geleistet und somit
werden die rücklagen geplündert und
momentan sieht der entwurf auch noch vor
dass die bundesagentur zum ausgleich
defizit eben keinen steuerzuschuss
bekommt sondern einen kredit und ich
fordere sie auf ändern sie das und
schließen sie begeisterten die
beschäftigten aus
kürzungen bei den sozialleistungen sind
nur auf den ersten blick billiger ein
starker sozialstaat ist deutlich mehr
wert als er kostet und deswegen sollten
sie den haushalt nachbessern vielen dank
nächster redner für die spd fraktion dr
martin rosemann
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
fortschritt und sicherheit sind zwei
seiten einer medaille
und gerade veränderungen verlangt
sicherheit
diese regierung diese ampel koalition
hat respekt sozialen fortschritt und
sozialen zusammenhalt versprochen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat am
mittwoch ja von diesem pult folgenden
satz gesagt die bürgerinnen und bürger
müssen spüren jede und jeder einzelne
zählt meinen beitrag meine anstrengung
wird wertgeschätzt und diese ampel
koalition hält wort wir werden den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöhen ab dem
ersten oktober
wir sicher wieder kurzarbeit
arbeitsplätze und wir unterstützen
private haushalte bei den gestiegenen
energiepreisen
gerade in zeiten der unsicherheit gilt
äußere sicherheit
innere sicherheit und sozialer
sicherheit gehören zusammen und dürfen
nicht gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
diese krise bewältigen wir nur wenn wir
als gesellschaft solidarisch zusammen
halten deshalb müssen wir weiterhin in
sozialen zusammenhalt investieren wir
müssen sicherstellen dass die hohen
energiepreise nicht von den kleinen
einkommen bezahlt werden und deswegen
entlastet diese ampel koalition die
bürgerinnen und bürger die wegen der
energiepreise finanziell
überfordert sind gezielt wir haben zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
zwei entlang sonst pakete und herma
dazwischen lag immerhin der beginn des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine das erste
entlastungspaket ist ja noch vor dem
krieg verabschiedet worden und jetzt
haben wir auf die aktuelle situation
nochmal reagiert mit dem zweiten
entlastungsschritt
also
ich sag immer
heizkostenzuschuss einmalzahlung für
unsere jungs beziehende beides
verdoppelt energiepreis pauschale und
einmalzahlungen für kinder damit sorgen
wir dafür dass starke schultern nicht
nur mehr leisten können sondern auch
mehr leisten wären als schwache
meine damen und herren
die herausforderungen der transformation
sind aber auch durch den krieg in der
ukraine nicht weg ganz im gegenteil das
muss jetzt alles sogar sehr viel
schneller gehen wir müssen schneller
unabhängig werden von fossilen energien
wir müssen schneller in regenerative
energien investieren in die
infrastruktur aber vor allem auch in die
köpfe und deswegen haben die vorhaben
des koalitionsvertrags eben nichts von
ihrer aktualität und bedeutung verloren
hinzu kommt die aufgabe menschen die
jetzt aus der ukraine zu uns kommen und
hier zuflucht suchen in gesellschaft und
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren
ja und der blick nach brüssel zu beiden
und kommissionspräsidentin ursula von
der leyen geben wollten wir ihnen
natürlich nicht vorenthalten die usa
sagen der europäischen union in diesem
jahr deutlich mehr energie gas
flüssiggas um die abhängigkeit von
russischen gaslieferungen
der bundestag debattiert heute am
letzten tag der haushaltsberatung zum
einzelplan arbeit und soziales ist
spricht im moment
ist die fraktion
kurz vor diesem hintergrund meine damen
und herren stellen sich für den
bundeshaushalt zwei wesentliche aufgaben
erstens wir müssen die bundesagentur für
arbeit in die lage versetzen dass sie
ihre aufgaben gut leisten kann das gilt
für die kurzfristigen aufgaben
insbesondere bei der kurzarbeit ich habe
es angesprochen und viele vorräten
weiterhin auch in der ukraine krise als
brücke über die krise funktionieren
kurzarbeit sichert existenz von
betrieben sichert beschäftigung und
sicher einkommen sichert im übrigen auch
die finanzielle stabilität der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung
auf der anderen seite
findest aber langfristige aufgaben die
fachkräftesicherung und die bewältigung
des strukturwandels unser anspruch als
andere koalition ist es jede und jeden
individuell in diesem wandel zu
unterstützen durch weiterbildung neue
perspektiven zu schaffen wir wollen
weiterbildungs weltmeister werden und
deshalb dürfen wir die bundesagentur für
arbeit für diese zukunftsaufgaben nicht
mit weiteren schulden belasten sondern
müssen ihnen einen zuschuss geben damit
sie entschuldet wird und diese aufgabe
angehen
zweitens
zwei es müssen wir die jobcenter in die
lage versetzen dass sie ihre aufgaben
leisten können dass sie einen beitrag
zur arbeitskräfte sicherung damit zum
besseren unterstützung von
langzeitarbeitslosen leisten können da
haben wir handlungsbedarf denn die
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit ist seit beginn
der pandemie um 200.000 gestiegen
und da haben wir auch chancen potenziale
zu heben und menschen besser zu
befähigen
ja und es geht darum dass wir auch
teilhabe für menschen organisieren die
sonst keine spektiven haben
ab dem 11 12 01 23 wollen wir das neue
bürgergeld einführen
auch das eine große aufgabe denn wir
wollen einen kulturwandel sicherstellen
da geht es nicht nur darum hier bisschen
mehr leistung und daten noch
instrumenten her nein da geht es um
einen kulturwandel hin zu individueller
unterstützung auf augenhöhe dazu
dazu meine damen und herren kommen in
den kommenden jahren die stabilisierung
der rente verbesserungen für
erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen und
erwerbsminderungsrentner und ein
umfassendes programm für
barrierefreiheit wir werden in den
haushaltsgesprächen darauf achten dass
all dies auch finanziert wird das gilt
zusammen für drei haushalte für den
haushalt 2022 der heute hier beraten
aber vor allem auch für den ergänzungs
haushalt für die zusatzaufgaben im
zusammenhang mit dem ukrainer krieg und
drittens auch für den haushalt 2023 der
ja im juni bereits ins bundeskabinett
kommt und alle weiteren haushalt meine
damen und herren es geht darum die
notwendigen mittel für
zukunftsinvestitionen zu zur verfügung
zu stellen und den sozialen fortschritt
und sozialen zusammenhalt zu investieren
das werden wir als ampel gemeinsam tun
er sagte martin rosemann der sprecher
für arbeit und soziales für die
spd-fraktion und ist es schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden die bundesagentur
für arbeit hat die vor der pandemie
aufgebauten sehr hohen rücklagen
aufgebraucht und wird noch mal einen
zuschuss des bundes bekommen vielleicht
noch ein bisschen was diejenigen
haushaltsberatung drauf denn auf die
bundesagentur kommt ja dann auch noch
die aufgabe zum beispielsweise auch
geflüchtete aus
wie möglich mit in den arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren
stefan anker für die cdu präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zu den
starts aufgaben zählen klassisch die
innere und äußere sicherheit
gegen putins krieg in der ukraine
ukraine sprechen wir aktuell aus gutem
grund viel über äußere sicherheit über
die ausrüstung der bundeswehr über
unsere verteidigungsfähigkeit um das
naso ziel der 2 prozent in einer
modernen ausdifferenzierten
arbeitsgesellschaft gehört zu den
zentralen starts funktionen aber eben
auch die soziale sicherheit sozialer
sicherheit dafür steht unser sozialstaat
es geht um sozialen frieden um ausgleich
um eröffnung von lebenschancen
innere äußere und soziale sicherheit das
eine kann man nicht ohne das andere
betrachten die kosten die jetzt
unmittelbar auf grund von
wirtschaftssanktionen für die versorgung
von kriegsflüchtlingen und ihre
integration in unsere gesellschaft
entstehen setzen unseren sozialhaushalt
stark unter druck
die ampel versucht das zu verschleiern
indem sich hinter bemühten
differenzierung von kernhaushalt
ergänzungs haushalt und sondervermögen
versteckt die menschen in unserem land
verdienen aber transparenz statt
schattenhaushalten
meine damen und herren wir sehen nicht
erst jetzt sondern schon seit ausbruch
der korona pandemie ängsten
in der bevölkerung verdrängt
zukunftsangst die zuversicht sie als
bundesregierung haben eine besondere
politische verantwortung für die
öffentliche diskussion und ihre
tonalität es ist fahrlässig wenn sie in
diesen schwierigen zeiten das vertrauen
der menschen in die politik noch
zusätzlich schwächen wenn sie bei der
rentenversicherung wie sie es bei der
rentenversicherung tun die zögern jede
auch noch so kleine reform hinaus vor
100 tagen sind sie dynamisch angetreten
sie wollten eine fortschritts koalition
sein aber schon jetzt macht sich lähmung
breit dabei treten sie nicht nur auf der
stelle
sie legen sogar den rückwärtsgang ein
auf 177 seiten koalitionsvertrag finde
ich keine gemeinsame idee für die rente
stattdessen übernehmen passagen aus der
allgemeinen prognosen der deutschen
rentenversicherung nach deren niveau und
beitragssatz stabilität für die dauer
dieser legislaturperiode als gesichert
gelten aber sie hätten weiter lesen
müssen diese prognosen besagen nämlich
auch das unmittelbar nach ende dieser
legislatur die kurven auseinandergehen
und die haltelinien gerissen werden das
können sie doch nicht einfach ignorieren
wo es ihr konzept
sie wollen unsere werte
umlagefinanzierte rente für den zeitraum
in dem die baby boomer in den ruhestand
gehen durch einkünfte aus dem
finanzmarkt entlasten ihre dafür
angekündigten 10 milliarden euro sind
aus dem haushaltsentwurf verschwunden
wenn sie es ernst meinen müssen sie aber
jetzt anfangen einen kapitalstock zu
bilden aber davon abgesehen ist die
verzinsung von zehn milliarden euro
angesichts eines jahres volumens in der
rente von über 300 milliarden euro ein
auch und nichts kein unterschlagen die
union steht mit ihrer kritik nicht
alleine da auch der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund warnt vor einem griff
in die rentenkasse dgb vorstandsmitglied
anja pilz kritisiert dass
bundesfinanzminister rind lamm das
sicherheitsversprechen für die rente
einfach aufgekündigt dass die ampel noch
zu jahresende in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
gegeben hat
stattdessen hat die ampel die
gesetzliche
für die jahre 2002 und 20 bis 25
festgeschriebene jährliche sonderzahlung
von 500 millionen euro einfach auf null
gekürzt ich finde das rechtswidrig und
das stört vertrauen
lieber herr heil wenn sie in der
nächsten zeit ihren koalitionsvertrag
neu aushandeln müssen weil der ukraine
krieg auch ihr politisches
koordinatensystem durcheinander gebracht
hat
berücksichtigen sie doch bitte das thema
rente angemessen die rente darf nicht
schlechtgeredet werden unser
umlagefinanzierte system ist gut es
bedarf nur angesichts sich immer wieder
verändernden gesellschaftlichen
rahmenbedingungen einer stetigen
nachsteuerung es geht nicht um weniger
als um die anerkennung der
lebensleistung von generationen und
zugleich um das im blick behalten der
leistungsfähigkeit der jüngeren und der
belastbarkeit der jüngeren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
vertrauen in die rente wird nur dann
wachsen wenn die verschiedenen
politischen richtungen an einem strang
ziehen so war es unsere gute tradition
gerne erinnere ich an dieser stelle an
meinen leider viel zu früh verstorbenen
politischen mentor karl schiewerling die
mit von ihm die von ihm mit geleitete
kommission
verlässlicher generationenvertrag hat
viele themen an diskutiert lassen sie
uns weitere schritte auf dieser basis
machen frei nach erich kästner es gibt
nichts gutes außer man tut es vielen
dank
stefan hackl war das für die cdu csu
fraktion mit seiner ersten rede hier im
bundestag er ist gewählt über die
landesliste der cdu in nordrhein
westfalen sein wahlkreis ist münster
zuvor war er mitglied des landtags in
nordrhein westfalen
jederzeit eingehalten bei ihrer ersten
rede sogar noch ein paar sekunden liegen
lassen herzlichen glückwunsch und alles
gute für ihre weitere arbeit hier im
haus
und der nächste redner hat sich schon
als bub gegeben für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und markus kurze
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube jetzt ist an dieser
debatte der punkt gekommen wo man die
cdu/csu mal politisch versteht sich am
schlafittchen packen muss wenn sie hier
auch ihre erfolgsbilanz verweisen und
auch
verantwortungsvolle politik hinweisen
dann muss man hier der redlichkeit
halber feststellen dass die guten jahre
zwischen der finanzkrise und der korona
krise mit höchster beschäftigung wo die
einnahmen sprudelten die sozialkassen
sich von selbst füllten nicht vorsorge
von ihnen betrieben worden ist wo
stünden wir
wenn sie in der letzten wahlperiode als
das qualifizierungs chancen gesetz kam
nicht im bremserhäuschen gestanden
hätten und zb weil der weiterbildung
mutigere schritte gemacht hätten das
wäre noch möglich gewesen
in der letzten wahlperiode als der
soziale arbeitsmarkt oder
teilhabechancen gesetz kam was wir sehr
unterstützt haben als bündnis 90 die
grünen da waren es doch sie die das
befristet haben und dadurch für
planungsunsicherheit bei den jobcentern
gesorgt haben das war keine
verantwortungsvolle politik
und bei der grundrente als sie
eingeführt wurde die von der
grundsystematik her ja durchaus unserer
garantierente entsprach da waren es doch
sie vorwiegend die das ganze
bürokratisiert aufgehalten und
intransparent gestaltet haben all die
möglichkeiten
all die möglichkeiten die ihnen der
regierungszeit lagen die sie hatten als
es gut lief haben sie verspielt und da
wo sie in verantwortung sind betreiben
sie das spiel ja weiter ich finde es
geradezu unfassbar dass markus söder in
bayern immer noch an den abstandsregeln
für die windräder festhält ja das müssen
sie sich mal vorstellen in dieser
situation und herr frey das ist durchaus
zum thema denn das ist
wirtschaftspolitisch sinnvoll der ausbau
der erneuerbaren und gerade mit
windkraft es ist sicherheitspolitisch
sinnvoll wie wir wissen klimapolitisch
sowieso und es hat einen effekt auf den
arbeitsmarkt und
das ist wirklich nicht vergessen und
verantwortungslos was sie an dieser
stelle hier betreiben und darum lassen
wir uns hier von der ampel koalition
überhaupt nichts von ihnen sagen was
mangelnde verantwortungsübernahme
anbelangt und von ihnen herr stracke von
der csu von der partei von herrn söder
lassen wir uns doch hier nicht vorhalten
wir müssen noch mehr machen das
entlastungspaket würde nicht groß genug
ausfallen haben sie gesagt das muss
jemand sagen der noch bis vor sechs
monaten sozialpolitisch im
bremserhäuschen gesessen hat und das
lassen wir nicht durchgehen vielen dank
markus kurth war dass die
rentenpolitische sprecher zu bündnis 90
die grünen
nächste rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion doktor silke launert
die erwiderung von silke reinert für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir sprechen
heute hier über den etat des
bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales also die finanziellen mittel
die der haushalt vorsieht für das
arbeitsministerium
ich würde trotzdem betonen weil das
natürlich ich weiß das gerät in einer
debatte immer so ein bisschen in
vergessenheit aber das ist eigentlich
der tagesordnungspunkt und deshalb
sollten wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen
noch mehr zum haushalt es sagen das geht
natürlich
für mich als die zuständige haushälterin
für diesen bereich und ich weiß dass das
nicht so gerne gehört wird dass man
bezahlen kommt wo man doch was gutes tun
will aber ich sage ihnen eins es hängt
zusammen man kann nur gutes tun wenn ich
vorher auch vernünftig langfristig gut
planung mit dem geld sinnvoll umgeht das
heißt jede familie und es geht auch für
den staat
hier haben wir den größten
einzelhaushalt über
160 mehr
und dieser uns vorliegende übrigens erst
anfang letzter woche zugeschickte zweite
entwurf des einzel plans denn
es kann jetzt noch veränderungen krohn
akquise teurer werden jetzt kam der
krieg dazu deshalb erst anfang letzter
woche ist eigentlich schon so nicht mehr
haltbar
diese 160 milliarden werden das kann man
schon jetzt ablesen nicht ansatzweise
das sein was dann letztlich wirklich
rauskommt warum nicht wie dann doch
erwartet also die großen herausforderung
zusammenhang mit dem ukraine krieg ist
es schon angesprochen worden ist wird
durch die verteuerung von öl und gas zu
erheblichen nachteilen bei den betrieben
zu kurzarbeitergeld kommen was natürlich
dazu führt dass der staat dann durch
zuschüsse unterstützt die agentur für
arbeit es wird eben neben kurzarbeit
auch vielleicht zu neuen kosten im
hinblick auf arbeitsmigration wenn es zu
arbeitslosen kommt geld kommen durch die
flüchtlingswelle werden die erhebliche
steigerung haben sei das bei sprach
schulungskurs sind langfristig natürlich
dann auch im sozial bei dem
sozialbereich am anfang machen es ja
noch die kommunen das heißt auch jetzt
ist absehbar dass in triesen beträge das
kommt dann alles erst in einen
ergänzungs haushalt den wir nicht kennen
ich hoffe wir sehen ihn bald das zeigt
welche fass wir haben aber das reicht
nicht es geht weiter ein test am einen
tag vor der debatte können wir dann von
dem paket ich begrüße in der sache des
paketes ist gut dass endlich was
passiert seit wochen ja seit monaten
wird dafür gekämpft und nun kommt
endlich was allerdings ist es uns
gegenüber und frechheit einen tag vor
der debatte es wir haben eine dreifach
völlig überholten haushalt über dinge
reden 160 milliarden nicht ansatzweise
mehr das widerspiegelt was es in
wahrheit geht
das hat dann mit den grundsätzen dass
man sich wer verhält eigentlich nichts
mehr zu tun im haushalt bereit und es
wundert mich besonders von der fdp nicht
nur dass wir jetzt schon bei dem
rückständig also schon dreimal
überholten etwa 100 milliarden ungefähr
kredit haben das noch ohne mehr um
zusätzlich kommt es noch vorher 60
milliarden an der schuldenbremse vorbei
gemogelt hat für den energie und
klimafonds nicht nur das
nein wir machen solche spielchen kurz
vor schluss noch das wir wissen
überhaupt gar nicht richtig über was wir
reden das haben wir zum fdp gelernt wir
haben uns vier vorträge anhalten lassen
über haushaltswaren klar ein und
generationengerechtigkeit alles
vergessen der wald wiese geführt worden
alles vergessen
der religions- vertrag vielleicht wollen
sie mal in einem koalitionsvertrag hören
was haben wir denn da also wir werden
all die gesetzliche rente stärken und
das mindestrente niveau von 48 prozent
dauerhaft sichern
sie wissen es selbst es war klar
geregelt oder ist es wird jetzt von
heute auf morgen wir schnell abschaffen
a500 mehr
500 millionen jedes jahr von 20 22 20 25
soll als sonderzahlung in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung der regen
sich die eigenen dinge bild vorstände
auf und auch nicht griff in die retten
kann obwohl von heute auf morgen
eingespart übrigens die halbe milliarde
zwar werden ein wertvoller beitrag zur
stabilisierung der beiträge einfach mal
rausgeflogen findet sich in position
dazu vertrag nichts nochmal
koalitionsfähig wurf nichts normal
koalitionsvertrag
wortwörtlich dazu werden wir in einem
ersten schritt der deutschen
rentenversicherung im jahr 20 22 war das
mit dezember also im dezember
versprochen 20 22 aus den
haushaltsmitteln füllen den kapitalstock
es geht um die ergänzung der aktien
unterstützten randy
koalitionsvertrag
20.000 was finden wir ein wurf nichts
nichts nichts
das ist wirklich alles andere
eine klare ware seriöse
generationengerechte haushaltsplanung
die herr leben ist ein desaster und es
wird nämlich weitergehen wenn wir weiter
so machen ist es nicht nur lindner leide
jetzt der schuldenkönig zeichnet sich ab
hat sich nur wie man schon lustig macht
jetzt ein es wird uns auch noch in
europa teuer kommen wenn wir selbst
nicht mehr ansatzweise das erfüllen was
wir eigentlich wieder in kraft setzen
wollen
meine oma eine sehr lebenserfahrene
leider auch kriegs der für gerne frau
hat gesagt ich habe nicht immer alles
verstanden und nicht jeder wunsch von
mir ist beschlossen worden aber oder den
schwarz ist uns immer besser gegangen
und sie haben noch was gesagt die linken
versprechen alles und halten nichts
laudert war das für die cdu/csu-fraktion
hier nochmal auch mit einem vehementen
auftritt zum ende dieser etat beratungen
ein redner haben wir aber noch zu diesem
einzelplan bevor wir dann so einen
getaufte familie freunden bietet
senioren kommen in letzterem hier rasch
an das natürlich ist die fraktion
werte kollegin launert ich glaube nach
dieser rede hat sich noch einmal
deutlich gezeigt warum es richtig ist
dass es jetzt neue
regierungsmehrheiten in diesem land
blieben die veranstaltung
auch präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren werte kolleginnen und
kollegen meine eltern sind 1986 aus
syrien in die ddr gekommen um ihr
studium der architektur an der tu
dresden zu beenden und als dann die
wiedervereinigung kam haben sie sich
dazu entschieden hier zu bleiben um sich
mein bruder und später dann auch mir
eine bessere perspektive bieten zu
können meine eltern haben ihre heimat
damals freiwillig verlassen sie haben
sich hier möglich eine existenz
aufgebaut und hatten dabei nicht immer
nur glück aber glück seien wir ehrlich
entscheidet leider immer noch viel zu
häufig darüber werden diesem land etwas
werden kann und in den letzten jahren
sind immer mehr menschen nicht
freiwillig zu uns gekommen sondern
wunder zu gezwungen wenn menschen ihre
heimat verlieren dann ist es unsere
oberste pflicht in schutz und zuflucht
zu gewähren
diese meldestelle dann bei uns egal ob
sie geflüchtet sind oder aus welchem
grund auch immer sich dazu entschieden
haben zu uns zu kommen dann ist es doch
auch unsere oberste pflicht ihnen alle
chancen zu geben sich hier eine eigene
perspektive aufbauen zu können und an
dieser stelle will ich kurz auf die
situation in der ukraine zu sprechen
kommen mittlerweile vier wochen dauert
dieser grausamen krieg an und mir
persönlich macht es mut dass wir nicht
nur in unserer härte gegenüber putin
sondern auch in unserem mitgefühl
gegenüber den menschen in der ukraine
vereint sind und dieses mitgefühl das
lässt sich auch politisch erkennen und
deswegen hoffe ich inständig dass das
jetzt der moment ist in dem wir unseren
umgang mit flucht migration und
integration auch und vor allem in
unseren arbeitsmarkt grundlegend
überdenken
dezember letzten jahres und des ersten
entwurfs für unseren haushalt sind noch
einmal über zehn millionen euro
zusätzlich für den bereich
fachkräftesicherung im einzelplan es
festgehalten das ist gut so denn für
große zukunft darauf gaben müssen auch
große zukunftsinvestitionen getätigt
werden und ich zitiere an dieser stelle
mit erlaubnis der präsident in den
staatssekretär im bundesinnenministerium
ist der letztens treffend formuliert hat
wir müssen aufhören den leuten zu sagen
du musst gehen weil sondern müssen
anfangen zu sagen du kannst bleiben wenn
und deswegen sind wir hier in der bring
fließt werte kolleginnen und kollegen
den arbeitsmarkt integration ist eine
der größten aufgaben unserer zeit
lassen und zuwanderung doch bitte
endlich auch als chance erkennt denn wir
sind doch schon längst ein
einwanderungsland meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren punkt wir sind
angewiesen oft die klugen köpfe von nah
und fern und dabei meine ich nicht nur
jene die bereits mit hochschulabschluss
oder doktortitel zu uns kommen sondern
auch jene die als fachkräfte aus so
vielen bereichen jetzt schon gar nicht
mehr wegzudenken sind ohne uns belegt
auf dem ausland geht nicht mehr und der
zeit müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
menschen einen niedrigschwelligen zugang
zum deutschen arbeitsmarkt bekommen und
dabei müssen wir aber auch darauf achten
dass das spiel nach unseren regeln durch
dazu gehören unter anderem ordentliche
arbeitsbedingungen und vor allem die
faire entlohnung von mindestens 12 euro
die stunde am besten aber nach tarif und
demokratie monster an das haben wir uns
auch als koalition festgehalten denn der
spitze bleiben will der muss sich auch
bewegen also lassen sie uns gemeinsam
dafür sorgen dass der deutsche
arbeitsmarkt auch in zukunft attraktiv
bleibt und noch besser wird sowohl für
unsere eigenen leute als auch für die
vielen klugen köpfe die es fachkräfte
hier zu uns kommen und auf die wir
angewiesen sind und perspektivisch noch
mehr sein werden und lassen sie uns
schließlich dafür kämpfen dass eben
nicht mehr glück darüber entscheidet wer
was werden kann sondern dass in diesem
wunderbaren land alle alles werden
können die ampel ist bereits dafür
vielen dank
löschwasser für die spd fraktion war
hier die letzte rednerin zu diesem
einzelplan
da die einzelpläne dann heute nachmittag
sozusagen in gänze mit dem entwurf des
haushaltsgesetzes überwiesen werden die
ausschüsse geht das jetzt ganz schnell
weiter zum letzten einzelplan in dieser
haushaltswoche und hier steht dass der
etat des ministeriums für familie
senioren frauen und jugend auf der
tagesordnung die zuständige ministerin
heißt alle spiegel kommt von den grünen
der entwurf kommen jetzt gerade von
arbeit und soziales dem größten etat 160
milliarden ausgaben für 2022 geplant im
vergleich dazu bei familie senioren
frauen und jugend 12 milliarden ausgaben
für 2022 geplant also einer der
kleineren etat sind bundeshaushalts der
größte einzelposten übrigens ist das
elterngeld hier sind alleine 7,7
milliarden euro eingeplant und schlagen
die bootsmotoren eingespart werden soll
bei der kinder und jugendpolitik das
wird sicher hier bei der aussprache ein
thema werden aber jetzt erstmal die
ministerin an der spiegel zu ihrem
einzelplan
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte abgeordnete und zu hören
am dienstag war ich mit rabbiner
teichtal in einer flüchtlingsunterkunft
am kudamm dort haben jüdische
waisenkinder und jüdische frauen mit
ihren kindern aus der ukraine eine
bleibe gefunden sie alle stammen aus
odessa mich hat beeindruckt mit welcher
herzlichkeit sie dort betreut werden das
jüngste kind war gerade einmal acht
wochen alt es hat noch ein ganzes leben
vor sich es ist jetzt in sicherheit und
gestern war ich gemeinsam mit der
vorsitzende von sos kinderdorf
deutschland frau professorin schottern
am sos kinderdorf und habe dort mit
ukrainischen frauen und ihren kindern
gesprochen einerseits ihren schmerz ihre
traumatisierung durch den krieg und die
dramatische flucht zu spüren aber
andererseits auch die erleichterung nun
hier in sicherheit zu sein und die
hoffnung begann in dem moment als sie am
bahnhof in berlin ein mitarbeiter mit
sos kinderdorf feste seien für diese
hoffnung in sicherheit zu sein und hier
schnell und unbürokratisch aufgenommen
zu werden danke ich stellvertretend für
alle die sich haupt und ehrenamtlich
engagieren sos kinderdorf und herrn
rabbiner teichtal es ist großartig denn
hier wird ganz schnell geholfen sie
mindern leid und sie geben hoffnung
[Musik]
das bundesfamilienministerium hilft ganz
konkret wir stehen bereit die
koordinierung für die evakuierten
waisenhäuser zu übernehmen mir ist es
sehr wichtig dass wir für diese kinder
die ohne eltern sind und die so viel
leid und tod erlebt haben so viel
geborgenheit und stabilität wie möglich
schaffen dazu gehört dass sie in ihren
vertrauten gruppen zusammen bleiben
können und dass sie nicht von ihren
betreuerinnen getrennt werden das
konzept für die koordinierungsstelle
liegt vor und wir haben starke partner
innen an unserer seite die
koordinierungsstelle soll ordnung
schaffen und anlaufstelle sein und wir
schauen genau hin was diese menschen
jetzt brauchen die aus der ukraine zu
uns kommen und dazu zählt auch der
entschlossene kampf gegen skrupellose
menschenhändler zuhälter und
sexualstraftäter die die verzweifelte
lage von frauen und kindern ausnutzen
wollen
unsere
expertinnen unsere expertinnen vom
koordinierungskreis gegen menschenhandel
vom hilfe telefon gewalt gegen frauen
und der hotline des unabhängigen
beauftragten für fragen des sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs arbeiten seite an
seite mit den polizeibehörden es gibt
solche soziale unterstützung und unsere
bewährten sprach und integrationskurse
beispielsweise diejenigen für mütter
gleichzeitig mit kinderbetreuung stehen
all jenen beiseite damit diese ersten
schritte der integration des
spracherwerbs und der teilhabe jetzt
schnell und unbürokratisch
begonnen werden kann
sehr geehrte abgeordnete der einzelplan
17 den wir heute einbringen es steht für
hilfe für förderung und für
unterstützung für alle kinder und ihre
familien in der bundesrepublik und der
größte posten finanziert die bekannteste
und beliebteste familienleistung in
deutschland das elterngeld dafür stehen
7,7 3 milliarden euro zur verfügung
er hilft müttern und vätern beruf und
familie noch besser zu vereinbaren und
zuletzt haben 42 prozent der väter
elterngeld in anspruch genommen mit
einer durchschnittlichen bezugsdauer von
3,7 monaten das ist eine sehr gute
entwicklung und darauf wollen wir
aufbauen und wir werden frau ministerin
entschuldigung gestatten wir eine
zwischenfrage oder zwischen bemerken aus
der fdp-fraktion nein ich möchte mein
haus nicht vertragen dank
der werden familien weiter entlasten mit
dem aufbau einer kindergrundsicherung
und damit das in seiner komplexität gut
funktioniert gibt es unter unserer
leitung eine interministerielle
arbeitsgruppe
kurzfristig entlasten wir von juli an
bedürftige familien mit dem sofort
zuschlag damit gibt es zusätzlich 20
euro pro kind pro monat beim
kinderzuschlag und ich bin sehr froh
dass auch geflüchtete kinder aus der
ukraine diesen kinder sofort zuschlag
bekommen
die bundesregierung unterstützt familien
auf vielfältige weise sei es beim ersten
entlastungspaket denn natürlich hilft es
auch familien wenn es ein
heizkostenzuschuss gibt oder das
kurzarbeitergeld aber auch mit dem
zweiten entlastungspaket helfen wir
familien durch am rhein mal bonus von
100 euro pro kind und zusätzlich zum
kindergeld und weiteren 100 euro vor
allem die sozialleistungen beziehen ein
wichtiges plus im geldbeutel für
familien in der aktuellen lage und wir
bleiben dabei nicht stehen
ein weiterer schwerpunkt ist das
aktionsprogramm auch hohl nach corona
für kinder und jugendliche für das wir
272 millionen euro bereitstellen aber
natürlich auch wichtige mittel um die
gleichberechtigung voranzutreiben um
frauen vor gewalt zu schützen um kinder
vor sexualisierter gewalt und missbrauch
zu schützen um quere menschen zu stärken
um trans menschen die von anfeindungen
betroffen sind zu stärken und wir werden
seniorinnen unter anderem durch den
digital packt alter stärken und die
situation von pflegebedürftigen
verbessern und wir haben eine strategie
gegen einsamkeit gestartet es gilt auch
die folgen von corona im blick zu halten
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
folgen des ukraine krieges sie fordern
entschlossenes handeln für waisenkinder
für unbegleitete minderjährige für
frauen für über 60 jährige und ein
besonderes augenmerk gilt den
hochbetagten holocaust überlebenden ich
will dass sie alle einen sicheren hafen
in deutschland tragen dass es unsere
verantwortung mehr als dass das ist
unsere humanitäre
verpflichtung und vermisse es aber auch
ja es gibt keine flüchtlinge erster und
zweiter klasse und eng damit verknüpft
ist unser entschlossenes engagement
gegen rassismus gegen antiziganismus
gegen antisemitismus durch die mittel
von demokratie leben meine damen und
herren
meine damen und herren ii war es
wichtiger als jetzt nie war es wichtiger
als jetzt entschlossen für die
demokratie und demokratische werte
einzutreten in deutschland aber auch
international und als jugendministerin
stehe ich dafür dass die junge
generation in einer vielfältigen
demokratie geprägt von solidarität und
respekt aufwachsen kann wir alle haben
es in der hand
für diese demokratischen werte
einzutreten dankeschön
war der spiegel war dass die
bundesfamilienministerin hier einleiten
zu ihrem etat ja einiges was im haushalt
steht hat sie genannt einiges an
vorhaben
noch nicht angeschoben ein zentrales
projekt der ampel die
kindergrundsicherung gestern hat an der
spiegel in einem interview gesagt eine
arbeitsgruppe dazu werdet sehr zeitnah
an den start gehen heute haben gehört
dass eine interministerielle
arbeitsgruppe
also das wird man mit sicherheit in den
nächsten wochen im auge behalten auch
hier im parlament silvia prieler jetzt
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
frau ministerin spiegel ihre koalition
hat ein zukunfts jahr zehn versprochen
aber wo ist ihr zukunfts jahrzehnt für
die familien und vor allen dingen für
die junge generation für unsere kinder
denn diese haushalt
mit vorstellen der es vor allen dingen
eins ein vertrag zulasten dritter ein
vertrag auf kosten unserer kinder und
deshalb müsste doch zumindest mit drin
sein in sein für unsere kinder der
haushalt des wären fsj beim amtsantritt
von angela merkel bei 4,5 milliarden
euro und hat sich in ihrer
regierungszeit bis 20 21 fast
verdreifacht auf 213 2 milliarden euro
und jetzt sind im jahr 22 nach zwei
jahren ohne inmitten der größten
flüchtlingskrise der blick auf familie
auf frauen kinder und jugend ist so
wichtig wie nie zuvor und jetzt kommen
sie frau ministerin spiegeln und
erstmals sind der etat ihres hauses auf
12,6 milliarden euro um eine halbe
million sie haben eine zeitenwende
versprochen sie haben eine zeitenwende
versprochen wir haben uns das etwas
anders vorgestellt
probieren
die entschuldigung kam
nicht in frage wenn sie uns also nun
bitte konkret und aktuell werden lassen
frau ministerin spiegel
bundesfamilienministerin wo sind sie wo
sind sie gewesen für einige flüchteten
frauen und kinder aus der ukraine
sie halten die leute empathische lieder
sind wie vor dann den schutz für die
kinder und für die frauen ein sie
fordern ein entschlossenes handeln aber
wochenlang dreieinhalb wochen bis
dienstag zu einem öffentlichen
pressetermin haben wir von ihnen nichts
gehört zum team aufbauen ein kind aus
der ukraine
sie fordern ein aber sie sind
bundesregierung und von ihnen hätte ich
antworten erwartet wie wollen sie den
schutz der frauen und kinder vor
zwangsprostitution und ausbeutung
sicherstellen welche angebote zur
traumabewältigung schaffen sie wie
sollen die ukrainische kinder integriert
werden und vor allen dingen wo finde ich
diese ideen in ihrem haushalt das sind
wir nämlich um keinen einzigen stelle
inhalt aber
als sonst haben sie in familien viel
versprochen die koalitionsvertrag ist
eine große wunschliste und auch sie
haben im januar hier eine reihe ideen
vorgestellt aber die finde ich auch mit
einer gruppe die im haushalt nicht bei
ihnen in der koalition stehen die
familien einfach an letzter stelle im
januar haben sie prioritär die reform
der elterngeld lösungen angekündigt mit
zwei heftige bestellseite freistellung
nach der geburt elterngeld für
pflegeeltern in ihrem haushalt ist
nichts dafür eingestellt und dann großes
versprechen die kindergrundsicherung aus
dem sofort zuschlag haben sie das sofort
gestrichen es kommt erst im sommer und
20 euro sind übrig geblieben aber die
eigentliche kindergrundsicherung die
eigentliche kindergrundsicherung sie
richten den arbeitskreis wir wollen in
dieser legislatur schaffen dann haben
wir uns die eckwerte angeschaut während
ihren haushalt noch in dem haushalt es
sind die eckwerte für die
kindergrundsicherung hinterlegt an
keiner einzigen stelle und was ist mit
einem weiteren
investitionsprogramm für die kinder
betreuungsausbau wir haben die
schriftliche frage der union gestellt
sie haben geantwortet sie würden ein
konzept ausarbeiten
aber wahr ist dann weiter das
investitionsprogramm für die kinder
betreuungsausbau weder 22 noch in der
langfristigen finanzplanung ihres hauses
enthalten warum denn die antragsfrist
für unser aus unserer regierungszeit
fünftes investitionsprogramm läuft mitte
diesen jahres aus also diese
bundesregierung stellt für einen ausbau
der kinderbetreuung im haushalt kein
geld zur verfügung und wurde schon beim
thema sind sie haben versprochen die
gute kitas gute kita gesetz was ende
dieses jahres ausläuft in ein qualitäts
entwicklungs gesetz fortzuentwickeln
nur und ja sie haben das schon liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der länder
achten sie mal genau darauf im jahr 2023
in den eckwerten sind keine mittel für
eine gute kita gesetz eingestellt die
eine fortführung des guter kita gesetz
sieht ihr haushalt nicht vor
und in jeder rede führen sie aus und
loben das aktionsprogramm aufholen nach
corona ja das programm ist richtig das
programm ist wichtig und es ist gut es
ist nämlich von uns es ist unser clown
aufgetreten 20.30 2-endstand sich mit
insgesamt zwei milliarden euro aufgelegt
und der alten bundesregierung was sie
jetzt fordert finanzieren zu minister
denn gerade im januar haben sie ein
neues zukunftspaket aufholen nach corona
angekündigt und was finden wir in den
eckwerten 23 50 millionen gegenüber 2
milliarden 21 22 da er stark uns jetzt
jeden kommentar und ich muss ihnen sagen
liebe koalitionäre liebe frau ministerin
ich kann jetzt verstehen was lesen sie
noch nicht im haus bei uns im ausschuss
gewesen sind weil ihre vorhaben 22 und
wir haben jetzt immerhin schon ende märz
die sind im haushalt einfach nicht
hinterlegt sie halten ihre versprechen
nicht leider aus sicht der familie
müssen wir an dieser stelle sagen und
wir hoffen dass sie dort entschädigung
nicht nachbessern werden an dem sie ihre
versprechen halten haben vielen dank
der harsche kritik und habe angriffe
hier von seiten der cdu csu fraktion
hier von silvia dreher der sprecherin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
und während ihrer rede gab es aber auch
diverse zwischenrufe die man leider
nicht so gut hier über die tonanlage
dann ja vermittelt verstehen kann
deswegen hören wir lieber was am
rednerpult weiter passiert als
erwiderung dieser welt kaiser für die
spd
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin
entschuldigung aber
entschuldigung
frau kaiser hat jetzt überwiegend das
wort am rednerpult
vielen dank vielen dank sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte frau
ministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte mitbürgerinnen
mitbürger seit zwei jahren befinden wir
uns in einer pandemie wir alle spüren
die auswirkungen und sind corona mögen
besonders gelitten haben in dieser zeit
kinder familien ältere und
pflegebedürftige menschen und die sie
pflegen zu dieser jahrhundert
herausforderungen von roth corona kommt
eine zweite krise die wir bisher nicht
für möglich hielten ein angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine ein krieg in europa
verbunden mit unheimlicher zerstörung
tausenden toten
vertreibung und flucht klar ist wir
stehen an der seite der ukraine einen
ukraine und wir helfen den geflüchteten
wir werden dafür sorgen dass ich vor
allen dingen frau und kinder ältere und
kranke menschen die zu uns kommen das
für sie unkompliziert und schnell
aufnehmen
wir wollen gemeinsam mit den ländern und
kommunen dafür sorgen dass sie sich bei
uns von den schlimmen erlebnissen ihrer
heimat unter flucht erholen können und
einer unterkunft in der sie sich sicher
und geborgen fühlen können
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen in diesem jahr nicht nur mit den
folgen der gesundheitskrise sondern auch
mit den folgen des krieges in der
ukraine umgehen deshalb ist es umso
wichtiger für stabilität sowie innere
und soziale sicherheit zu sorgen das tun
wir als ampelkoalition mit diesem
haushalt
wir werden dazu beitragen
die folgen der pandemie abzufedern mit
den ergänzungs haushalt werden der auch
die auswirkungen des ukraine kriegs und
den steigenden energiepreisen reagieren
die beschlossene entlastungspaket werden
sich darin wiederfinden klar ist aber
auch dass wir die ziele dieser koalition
dabei nicht aus dem blick verlieren
wir wollen unser land in eine gute
zukunft führen deshalb investieren wir
in familien kinder und jugendliche wie
endes tieren den gleichberechtigung und
schutz für frauen und kindern
unterstützung für ältere menschen und
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt wir
wollen dass jede und jeder in
deutschland die hier ihr zuhause nennen
an unserer demokratie teilhaben und sich
sicher fühlen können
12,7 milliarden euro ist dieser haushalt
des bundesministeriums für familie
frauen senioren senioren und jugend
schwer ich möchte anhand einiger punkte
verdeutlichen wie die koalition auf die
aktuellen herausforderungen reagiert und
dazu möchte ich zunächst auf diejenigen
aufmerksam machen die in den letzten
zwei jahren viel zu wenig gehört wurden
kinder und jugendlicher in der pandemie
haben sie besonders gelitten aber von
ihnen hat man am wenigsten gehört
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir sie mit
diesem haushalt besonders an den fokus
nehmen wir wollen ihnen die möglichkeit
bieten versäumtes nachzuholen deren
lücken zu schließen und sie unterstützen
in ihr soziales leben zurückzufinden
dafür starten wir das aktionsprogramm
aufholen nach gronau mit mehr als 200 72
millionen euro aus damit finanzieren wir
unter anderem lernangebote sowie sport
und freizeitaktivitäten und mit blick
auf die korona pandemie und ihre
auswirkungen auf die entwicklung unserer
kinder bin ich sehr froh dass wir
programme die sprach kitas und kita
einstieg in diesem jahr auf stärkeren
niveau fördern wollen besonders kindern
aus bildungsfernen familien und familien
mit migrationshintergrund profitieren
von den zusätzlichen fach pädagoginnen
und pädagogen in den kitas und ich bin
davon überzeugt dass wir hier an der
richtigen stelle geld in die hand neben
nicht nur weil ich einige dieser
einrichtungen in thüringen besuchen
konnte sondern auch recht davon
überzeugt denn das sprache das
wichtigste tor zur gesellschaftlichen
teilhabe ist
auch ein anderer stelle unterstützen wir
die förderung von kindern und
jugendlichen haushalterisch wir wollen
die mittel des kinder- und jugendplan
erhöhen das wichtigste förderinstrument
auf bundesebene im bereich der kinder-
und jugendhilfe wird dem mehr als 30
millionen euro an zusätzlichen mitteln
unterstützen wir die rechte von kindern
und jugendlichen auf schutz förderungen
beteiligung für einen gleichberechtigten
zusammenhalt lebendig wird diese
förderung durch enge kooperationen mit
ländern kommunen und den trägern der
kinder- und jugendhilfe und als mitglied
der naturfreunde thüringen der
landesvereinigung kulturelle
jugendbildung thüringen aber eben auch
als schwester eines sozialarbeiters in
meiner heimatstadt gera da weiß ich wie
wichtig diese förderung ist und wie sehr
sie vor ort gebraucht wird
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte ein mir persönlich sehr wichtiges
anliegen ansprechen was auch die
ministerin betont hat nämlich die
demokratie förderung wie
zivilgesellschaft ist so ein
unverzichtbarer teil unserer demokratien
unserer kommunen wir wollen den menschen
den rücken stärken die für unsere
demokratie gesicht und mut zeigen sind
sie führen die städte und gemeinden mit
leben für die stärkung von
und hierbei toleranz und demokratie ist
für 2022 die rekordzahl von mehr als 183
millionen euro eingestellt davon allein
165 5 millionen euro für das programm
demokratie kann mit demokratie leben das
sind 15 millionen euro mehr im vergleich
zum letzten jahr und damit ist das
programm demokratie leben die
wesentliche unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft eine demokratie
förderung
mit dem programm stärken und helfen wir
allen menschen die sich tagtäglich für
unsere demokratie einsetzen und sich
mutig rechtsextremen und anderen formen
gruppenbezogener menschenfeindlichkeit
entgegenstellen das engagement ist nicht
selbstverständlich und dafür möchte ich
an dieser stelle ganz herzlich danke
sagen danke ihnen und euch für euren
einsatz und
ich freue mich freue mich wirklich sehr
dass die bundesministerinnen nennt sich
leser und an die spiegel noch in diesem
jahr gemeinsam des demokratie
fördergesetz vorstellen wollen mit dem
das engagement dazu die gesellschaft auf
eine verlässliche und planbare basis
gestellt wird das sind genau das sind
die signale an die hier engagierten und
ich bin mir sicher und arbeitet gerne
daran mit dass dieses grundlagen gesetzt
nachhaltig wirkt und an dieser stelle
möchte ich auch die zusätzlichen mittel
für die deutsche stiftung für ehrenamt
und engagement erwähnen die noch relativ
junge stiftungen ist mit dem anspruch
angetreten das ehrenamt und engagement
vor allem in den strukturschwachen und
ländlichen räumen zu unterstützen und
als thüringerin muss ich leider immer
noch sagen dass der förderschwerpunkt
dame zu den ostdeutschen bundesländern
liegt dass die stiftung ihren anspruch
belegen ist ein moment liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das ist jetzt aber auch ein
bisschen misslich neben diskussionen zu
führen vielleicht lassen wir erst mal
die rednerin reden und dann können sie
ja auch in ihren debattenbeiträgen noch
drauf eingehen bitteschön vielen dank
frau präsidentin ich war bei der
stiftung zu ehren anderes engagement
möchte sagen dass die stiftung ihren
anspruch gerecht geworden ist ich kann
nicht aus eigener erfahrung als lokale
abgeordnete sagen aber eben auch als
mitglied im stiftungsrat noch auf den
krieg in der ukraine hat so schnell
reagiert online informationen
veröffentlicht sowohl für hilfesuchende
als auch für menschen die sich
ehrenamtlich einbringen wollen damit die
stiftung auch zukünftig ihr engagement
als einer breiter unterstützen kann ist
es wichtig sie auch weiterhin
auskömmlich zur finanz liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es gibt in diesem haushalt
noch viel gutes und wichtiges was ich
wegen der redezeit auch noch schlagartig
nennen kann erwähnt seien die maßnahmen
für den schutz für vor gewalt für frauen
und kinder dass wir diese sichern und
stärken wir stärken die bundesstiftung
gleichstellung geben den diensten den
freiwilligendiensten planungssicherheit
und unterstützen die wohlfahrtsverbände
bei ihrer wichtigen arbeit und mit dem
kinder sofort zuschlag sorgen wir dafür
dass 2,9 millionen armutsgefährdete
kinder und jugendliche bessere chancen
auf gesellschaftliche teilhabe haben und
gleichzeitig gehen wir damit den ersten
schritt in eine kindergrundsicherung
und ihre kolleginnen zu legen das sind
das sind in diesem jahr meinen ersten
haushaltsberatungen und hinsichtlich der
aktuellen situation in europa sicherlich
auch keine einfachen wenn wir aber
fortschritt in deutschland reden wenn
wir davon reden dann ist es mir wichtig
dass wir alle menschen alle menschen
einbeziehen die in diesem land leben in
zeiten des schnellen wandels und der
veränderungen wollen wir den bürgerinnen
und bürgern sicherheit geben der
vorliegende haushalt ist für uns
abgeordnete dafür eine gute grundlage
aber sie ist sicherlich auch immer
verbesserungswürdig und deshalb freue
ich mich auf die weiteren beratungen
dank sagte elisabeth kaiser für die spd
fraktion ja und während ihrer rede ging
es im nachgang hierzu mit der rede von
silvia bär von der cdu doch noch
zwischen grünen und sylvia brille oder
chance von den grünen auf bitte
hasselmann wie
fraktionsvorsitzende war nochmal in den
reihen der union und haben mit silvia
prieler gesprochen die scharfe kritik
geäußert hatte aber vielleicht kann man
das dann am rednerpult bei den nächsten
rednern werden hier grüne und cdu noch
mal zu wort kommen dann noch mal
thematisieren martin reichert wenn wir
jetzt für die ard
der diesjährige haushalt wird erstmals
in erheblichem maße von feministen
verantwortet feministische
familienpolitik steht im zeichen des
spiegel ismus der spiegel ismus ist die
endstufe des feministischen egoismus und
erlebt einen traurigen höhepunkt während
der flutkatastrophe im aartal als
feministisches egoismus auch menschen
leben in großer zahl zum opfer fielen
meine damen und herren ihr motto frau
spiegel wenig scheren die toten
hauptsache das image stimmt
der spiegel ismus führt wie sie frau
spiegel zeigen in eine täter opfer
umkehr die jede ungerechtigkeit gegen in
eine die jene kritik in eine
ungerechtigkeit gegen die eigene person
umdeutet der spiegel ismus verhindert
dass sie frau ministerin durch rücktritt
wenigstens reste von anstand zeigen sie
aber kleben an ihrem stuhl als schandmal
dieses charakters und als katastrophe
für familien
im feministin feministischer nabelschau
ist es nicht verwunderlich dass die
demographische katastrophe keine
erwähnung im haushalt findet und auch
keine geburten fördernde politik
stattfindet obwohl der demograf die
demographische katastrophe mit einem
bestands verlust der einheimischen
bevölkerung von 25 prozent von
generation zu generation unser land und
unsere sozialsysteme existenziell
bedroht meine damen und herren
die großen posten dieses haushalts
elterngeld 7,7 milliarden kinderzuschlag
1,37 milliarden und unterhaltsvorschuss
eine milliarde bleiben nahezu
unverändert
politisch bleibt es aber bei der linken
tradition kümmerliche initiativen mit
klingenden namen zu versehen
aktuellstes beispiel der kinder sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro im monat das sind
einige liter diesel die sie das
spendieren der mit dem namen kinder
verhöhnen zuschlag sicherlich besser
beschrieben worden wäre
aber auch hier sorgt der spiegel ismus
mit der wirtschaftspolitik des alls
gutem feministen bekannten herrn habeck
für ganz neue perversionen feministen
haben durch gewaltige teuerungsraten bei
lebensmitteln energie kraftstoffen die
existenznot ärmerer familien und auch
von frauen dramatisch verschärft und das
gilt es hier festzustellen
herr beck schuf so die grundlage auf der
sich der feministische egoismus der
ministerin erneut entfalten kann
familien in not bilden nämlich für
diesen egoismus nur ein bühnenbild wie
es auch schon die ereignisse im aartal
gebildet haben warum frau spiegel sie
wissen ganz genau dass weder die jetzt
angekündigten mit liegen entlastungen
noch die geplante kindergrundsicherung
und schon gar nicht der kinder sofort
zuschlag die folgen feministischer
politik und die daraus entstandene
teuerungswelle für die menschen auch nur
annähernd ausgleichen können
diese wahrheit aber verschweigen sie den
menschen sie verschweigen sie deshalb
weil sie sich insbesondere für die
kindergrundsicherung der einst noch als
retterin der armen und unterstützerin
feiern lassen wollen das ist unehrlich
und ihr motto ihr motto lautet letzten
endes wieder wen schert die verarmung
von kindern und familien hauptsache mein
image stimmt meine damen und herren
zur feministischen image-pflege zählen
auch millionen von euro die in bund und
land für gleichstellungs propaganda
ausgegeben werden was wurde nicht hier
im plenum schon alles verkündet
feministische politik sichert ein
friedliches zusammenleben
feministische politik sorgt für mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit frauen können
alles das patriarchat und die männer
sind schuld an allem ungleichheit ein
zwist und allen mal lesen meine damen
und herren
das ist aber dass es aber die politik
ausgewiesen nach feministen ist die
armut von familien und damit auch von
frauen hervorbringt wird ebenso
verschwiegen wie die tatsache dass es
eine feministische
verteidigungsministerin und
außenministerin ist die nachdem ihre
parteien das militär seit jahrzehnten
verhöhnt haben jetzt plötzlich bei
lockheed martin shoppen gehen wollen und
dort sogar atombombe einkaufen möchten
meine damen und herren und um das um das
alles zu finanzieren hat man nicht etwa
die kreditkarte mitgenommen sondern man
hat sich ein sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro in die tasche gesteckt
meine damen und herren
und wenn wir dann das feministische
motto hier ansehen dann können wir
folgendes sagen was stören uns armut und
atomkrieg hauptsache das image stimmt
das war so und das bleibt so
am schluss am schluss meine damen und
herren müssen nur noch alle kritiker
dieses ganzen irrsinns mundtot gemacht
werden und das geschieht durch die
massive förderung des sogenannten
kampfes gegen rechts jeder der heute dem
irrsinn der feminismus gesteuerten ampel
widerspricht wird mit totschlag
begriffen diffamiert klimaleugner corona
leugner frauenfeindlich trans feindlich
ausländerfeindlich neuerdings in mode
putin verstehe und der dauerbrenner
rechtsextrem das sind die schlagworte
mit denen sie andere meinungen kaputt
machen meine damen und herren
und dann gilt der mensch eben als rechts
und fällt dem oppositions bekämpfung
programm zum opfer das mit 165 millionen
ausgestattet ist und verlogener weise
demokratie leben heißt meine damen und
herren
das feministische motto lautet in diesem
zusammenhang wer an unserem image kratzt
der muss eben
heinz rudolf kunze hat einmal gesagt
traut keinem sänger ich rufe ihnen zu
traut keinem feministen und seiner
politik denn der mensch männlichen
chauvinismus zu recht kritisiert der
muss eben auch mit feministischem tun
auch wenn er von frau ministerin spiegel
kommt vielen dank
herr abgeordneter reichert die harte
auseinandersetzung in der sache ist
absolut angebracht und ist hier ja auch
gewollt ich muss aber ganz zum anfang
ihrer rede noch mal zurückkommen ich
denke dass man opfer von solchen
schweren ereignissen wie der
flutkatastrophe hier nicht
instrumentalisieren sollte um die eigene
meinung über zu können ich sag ihnen das
wert
sie können sich das ja auch mal anhören
[Applaus]
ich habe sie auf etwas aufmerksam
gemacht und sie können ja vielleicht mal
drei sekunden drüber nachdenken
als nächste rednerin in dieser debatte
und wenn sie noch ihre maske bitte
wieder aufsetzen würden als nächste
rednerin in dieser debatte bekommt
claudia raffelhüschen für die fdp das
wort
[Applaus]
diese erfreulich dass alle so wach sind
aber jetzt hören wir der rednerin frau
raffelhüschen schülern
[Applaus]
ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
es hier schon mehrmals gesagt werde es
aber gerne nochmals wiederholen auf
meiner politischen agenda steht das wohl
unserer kinder ganz oben sie und die
folgenden generationen sollen nicht wie
sisyphos vor einem schuldenberg stehen
den wir teils aus not teils aus
bequemlichkeit aufgehäuft haben sondern
sie sollen in jeder hinsicht auch
wirtschaftlich die nötigen freiräume
haben sich zu entwickeln und ihre
persönlichen lebensziele erreichen
können das und genau das ist
nachhaltigkeit im haushaltsrechtlichen
kontexten
zum einzelplan 17 passt das natürlich
ganz hervorragend nirgends geht es um
die zukunft unseres landes wie hier
unsere kinder sind unsere zukunft das
klingt ziemlich banal und abgedroschen
ja man muss es aber immer wieder holen
aber das macht es nicht weniger richtig
oder relevant fakt ist die korona
pandemie hat die globalen probleme auf
geradezu
schwindelerregende weise verschärft fakt
ist aber auch dass die pandemie in
deutschland auf ein extrem reiches gut
entwickeltes land getroffen ist und wir
vieles besser überstanden haben als
andere länder dennoch sind auch bei uns
große und man muss es leider so sagen
vermeidbare schäden entstanden
finanzielle materielle
gesundheitliche und seelische und die
hauptleidtragenden waren aus meiner
sicht die frauen familien und
insbesondere die kinder
niemanden wurde so viel zugemutet wie
ihn und das obwohl in der entwicklung
eines kindes ein jahr geschweige denn
zwei oder drei jahre buchstäblich welten
sind in denen so unglaublich viel
passiert und die sich nicht mal eben so
nachholen lassen wie ein urlaub ein
projekt oder eine fortbildung über deren
ausfall wir als erwachsene und schon
genug geärgert haben
nachdem wir nun als über zwei jahre lang
durchaus zu recht von kindern und
familien solidarität und opfer gefordert
haben und diese opfer wurden weit
überwiegend mit großem verständnis an
toller disziplin gebracht ist es nun an
der zeit ihnen eine ganze menge
zurückzugeben und die kinder wieder in
das zentrum unserer aufmerksamkeit zu
stellen
unkomplizierter unterstützung mit einem
wertschätzenden blick auf das was
familien sind und für unsere
gesellschaft leisten und natürlich auch
mit haushaltsmitteln ich bin daher sehr
froh dass im regierungsentwurf für
unseren einzelplan noch einmal
272 millionen euro zusätzliche mittel im
corona aufholt programm stehen von denen
der größte teil kindern jugendlichen und
familie zukommt und auch wenn es
mitunter fast schon negativ dargestellt
wird dass der großteil des einzelplan 17
in gesetzlichen leistungen gebunden und
daher nicht zu flexibel einsetzbar ist
muss man doch festhalten dass diese
gesetzlichen leistungen wie elterngeld
oder der kinderzuschlag eine ganze menge
bewirken und gerade auch während der
pandemie für millionen familien
unverzichtbare hilfe und finanzielle
stabilität bedeuten
denn das ein ganz normales familienleben
auch im 21 jahrhundert und sogar in
europa keine selbstverständlichkeit ist
wo wir uns jetzt durch den krieg in der
ukraine nochmals ganz brutal vor augen
geführt die kinder von zurückbleibenden
vätern und ihren flüchtenden frauen und
kindern sind nicht zu ertragen viele von
ihnen suchen bei uns in deutschland
schutz und finden ihn glücklicherweise
auch die hilfsbereitschaft der
ehrenamtlichen helfer ist beeindruckend
aber sie alleine wird nicht ausreichen
auch bund und länder sind gefragt und
diese neue zusätzliche große aufgabe im
bereich der familienpolitik zu stemmen
es ist daher in jeder hinsicht richtig
dass wir im regierungsentwurf wieder
mehr als 2,5 milliarden euro für den
einzelplan 17 vorsehen die aufgaben in
diesem bereich sind gigantisch und die
ausgaben sind investitionen in die
zukunft unserer familien und unseres
sozialen zusammenlebens in all seinen
facetten
vielen dank
claudia raffelhüschen kaders für die fdp
fraktion
sie sitzt im haushaltsausschuss und
werden sie hier heute morgen die
beratungen schon länger verfolgen haben
sie gemerkt dass sie heute sogar schon
zum zweiten mal gesprochen hat genauso
übrigens wie die nächste rednerin die
schon mehrfach in dieser woche
besprochen hat gesine lötzsch für die
linke stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und auch zuständig
für haushalt
jedes fünfte kind in deutschland gilt
als armutsgefährdet so die antwort der
bundesregierung auf eine anfrage meiner
fraktion das sind fast drei millionen
kinder und jugendliche in unserem
reichen land das ist beschämend dass
diskriminiert und minderten leben
schaffen so darf das nicht weitergehen
und es ist auch nicht nur zutiefst
ungerecht sondern es schadet der
gesamten gesellschaft denn große soziale
unterschiede zum schlecht für die
entwicklungschancen der gesamten
gesellschaft daran muss man immer wieder
in
einen spiegel sie sprachen über die
kindergrundsicherung ich kann ihnen nur
sagen es eilt wenn die bundesregierung
beziehungsweise die koalition mit
unterstützung der union quasi über nacht
ein sondervermögen aufrüstung von 100
milliarden euro beschließen kann dann
muss es doch auch möglich sein innerhalb
eines jahres die kindergrundsicherung zu
verabschieden haben
die diakonie hat berechnet dass kinder
in der grundsicherung monatlich 78 euro
zu wenig erhalten das fressen für
kleidung für freizeitaktivitäten und das
ist ungerecht
[Applaus]
20 euro im monat bekommen und der
finanzminister war nicht bereit ihnen
mehr zuzugestehen
sie dürfen sich frau spiegel nicht
weiter von finanzminister von der fdp
über den tisch ziehen lassen ein guter
plan wäre dass der haushaltsausschuss
jetzt die arbeit macht ihr bis zur
zweiten lesung 78 euro für jedes kind
das wäre doch ein gutes klima in st
stellen sie sich einmal drei minuten
lang vor aus dem sondervermögen
aufrüstung wird ein sondervermögen von
100 milliarden euro gegen kinderarmut
dann werden natürlich diese 78 euro
überhaupt kein problem
beim kampf gegen die kinderarmut müssen
sie deutlich nachlegen da haben sie
unsere volle unterstützung frau
ministerin
der haushaltsausschuss bei der haushalt
zu ihrem ministerium umfasst nach dem
plan 12,6 milliarden euro eine
vergleichszahl für die atombombe f-35
sollen 15 milliarden euro ausgegeben
werden mehr als für familien senioren
frauen und jugend zusammen in einem jahr
und ich glaube dieses geld diese 15
milliarden euro während viel besser in
einem ministerium angelegt dass sich für
familien für jugend für frauen einsetzt
diese änderung muss unbedingt erfolgen
meine damen und
menschen um das grundgesetz geändert
werden soll dann kann ich alle nur
auffordern endlich eine 30 jahre alte
forderung ins grundgesetz zu schreiben
nämlich kinderrechte ins grundgesetz
vielen dank
gesine lötzsch war das für die linke die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
und jetzt hören wir für die grünen ist
der abgeordnete wohnen würde
er ist mitglied im haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen lieber eine spiegel
dass sie hier tendenziös von einer
dreiwöchigen auszeit oder abwesenheit
der ministerin sprechen dass sie diese
debatte instrumentalisieren für diesen
popanz obwohl sie wissen dass die
ministerin drei wochen an corona
erkrankt ist dass die long gobet hat wie
millionen menschen in diesem land das
ist an respektlosigkeit und
schamlosigkeit nicht so überwiegend ob
er werde ich in ihrer fraktion ich würde
mich schämen für diese harmlosigkeit
schämen sich korea
liebe anne spiegel ich freue mich dass
wir wieder bei uns bis ich freue mich
dass wir gemeinsam jetzt für eine
konstruktive für eine ziel- und
lösungsorientierte gesellschaft und
familienpolitik kämpfen können ich freue
mich dass wir schluss machen können mit
all den altlasten die sie uns
hinterlassen haben das gehen wir an
widerspiegeln liebe
kolleginnen die koalition hat sich im
bereich der gesellschaft und
familienpolitik viel vorgenommen und
erste maßnahmen bereits auf den weg
gebracht der 219 a wird aus dem
strafgesetzbuch gestrichen die
ministerin hat es auf den weg gebracht
und das ist so überfällig endlich machen
wir schluss mit diesen
gesellschaftspolitischen unrecht
aber
ich möchte nochmal anknüpfen an das was
die ministerin auch schon gesagt hat die
menschen in der ukraine gehen aktuell
durch die hölle es ist ein gebot der
menschlichkeit zu helfen jetzt wo die
not so groß ist im angesicht der
russischen aggression ich bin der
ministerin dankbar dass sie sich dieser
aufgabe entschlossen stellt und viele
spezifische hilfsangebote auf den weg
bringt die idee zum schutz
alleinreisende frauen die die zum schutz
schwangere oder von waisenkinder oder
eben auch die evakuierung von
pflegebedürftigen holocaust-überlebenden
das ist so wichtig liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
deutschland ist in der verantwortung
deutschland stellt sich seiner
verantwortung wir helfen den menschen in
der not es ist wichtig dass wir
versuchen so schnell wie es irgendwie
geht ein stück normalität zurück zu
gewinnen für die schutzsuchenden dass
wir gemeinsam organisieren dass
insbesondere die kinder in schulen und
kitas gehen können für uns alle für die
kommunen und für die länder für den bund
ist es jetzt eine große kraftanstrengung
die wir gemeinsam vollbringen werden
dabei ändert sich die lage so dynamisch
dass ich es für richtig finde das ist
die richtige entscheidung ist dass die
bundesregierung hier einen ergänzungs
haushalt auflegt der ein teil dieser
kraftanstrengung abbilden wird und
gerade
und gerade vor dem hintergrund der
familie und kinder die zu uns kommen ist
der kita und ganztags ausbau so wichtig
und ich werbe dafür dass wir ein
sofortprogramm in den ergänzungs
haushalt aufnehmen
der bereits vorliegende entwurf für den
etat des bfj weist mit 12,58 milliarden
euro zusätzliche 147 millionen im
vergleich zum ersten regierungsentwurf
der vorgängerregierung auf das sind 147
millionen euro zusätzlich für familien
für die jugend für die
gleichberechtigung dieses geld ist gut
angelegt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der mit 86 prozent größte teil des etats
ist für die gesetzlichen leistungen
vorgesehen allen voran das elterngeld
dieses instrument wird gut angenommen
und es trägt maßgeblich zur
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf bei
aber wir werden es noch besser machen
indem wir es vereinfachen indem wir es
digitalisieren und indem wir die
gemeinschaftliche elterliche
verantwortung stärken
und auch im programmbereich ist diese
regierungsentwurf ein guter erster
aufschlag für das parlamentarische
verfahren
da möchte ich insbesondere auf die
erhöhung des ansatzes für das programm
auch wonach corona für kinder und
jugendliche verweisen dass deutlich
aufgestockt wurde auf 272 millionen euro
gerade nach corona brauchen kinder
jugendliche und familien weiterhin
unsere unterstützung und diese
unterstützung bekommen sie von dieser
bundesregierung
das bfj unter anderem spiegel steht für
unsere lebendige demokratie für vielfalt
und für eine moderne gesellschaft
deswegen ist es gut dass wir den ansatz
für die demokratie förderung und
extremismus prävention auf 184 millionen
euro aufstocken dass wir das
erfolgsprogramm demokratie leben um 15
millionen ausbauen und das das
patenschaftsprogramm menschen stärken
menschen um 18 millionen all das sind
investitionen die unsere demokratie noch
wehrhafter machen die früher ansetzen
und damit besonders wirkungsvoll sind
angesichts der multivan
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
muss ich anmerken dass ich mich sehr
gefreut hab' über das klare bekenntnis
von finanzminister christian lindner zur
kindergrundsicherung am dienstag dieser
woche mit der kindergrundsicherung
werden wir kinderarmut bekämpfen eines
der probleme unserer zeit denn wir alle
wissen dass sich armut reproduziert dass
das aufstiegsversprechen wegen ist die
kindergrundsicherung ein so wichtiges
projekt dieser ampelkoalition wir wollen
chancengerechtigkeit für unsere
kleinsten und nicht weniger als das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und lassen sie mich abschließend
bemerkten das natürlich nicht alle
unserer gesellschaftspolitischen
vorhaben jetzt schon etwas sind aber das
schmälert nicht ihre bedeutsamkeit und
auch nicht unsere entschlossenheit den
koalitionsvertrag in diesem bereich voll
umfänglich umzusetzen anführen will ich
neben der kindergrundsicherung auch dass
die familienpflegezeit oder die frauen
hausfinanzierung um nur einige der
wichtigen projekte in der zuschnitt nur
die chancen und
generationengerechtigkeit birgt
die uno hülle war das für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen hier zum familie
meter
das elterngeld hat er nochmal besonders
hervorgehoben na ja ein ganz großer teil
dieses etats dance eltern gilt schließt
7 3 milliarden euro für die union jetzt
hier die partner hero spur johann mit
jedem ausschuss für familie senioren
frauen und jugend
ich weiß nicht was ich da verbrochen
haben dass man meine zweite silbe betont
ich glaube das kommt aus dem russischen
also die betonung ist studio an dem ich
das mal zu protokoll
die hacken sehr verehrte damen und
herren der haushalts des haushalts der
entwurf das haushaltsgesetz 40 22 liegt
auf dem tisch es spiegelt aber nicht im
ansatz die
angekündigten familienpolitischen
vorhaben der ampel koalition wieder der
kollegen oder das eben ja auch
entsprechend ausgeführt aber auch der
entwurf des gesamthaushalts ist
insgesamt unsolide ein nachtragshaushalt
ist bereits in planung
sondervermögen nebenhaushalte und eine
deutliche erhöhung der verschuldung das
ist nicht nachhaltig und nämlich noch an
viele reden von christian lindner hier
der das natürlich auch alles früher
begeistert hat das ist generation
ungerecht diese enorme verschuldung
der einzelplan 17 beläuft sich nur noch
auf 12,6 milliarden euro das ist eine
etwas geringere summe als zehn jahren
zuvor das macht drei prozent des kern
haushaltes und der großteil dieses
haushaltes das sind gesetzliche
leistungen für familien das elterngeld
oder der kinderzuschlag und ja auch in
manchen titeln steigen die ansätze um
kleine beträge
aber was macht denn die regierung
überhaupt
in der familienpolitik wo setzt sie
schwerpunkte wo werden
familienpolitische neue entscheidungen
getroffen es gehört ja zur wahrheit dass
viele familien politische schwerpunkte
nicht in ihrem ressort frau ministerin
spiegel entschieden werden
beispielsweise die einführung einer
verantwortungsgemeinschaft die
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a oder
auch das steuerliche kindergeld denn
familienpolitik ist immer auch
bildungspolitik rechtspolitik steuer und
finanzpolitik sie schlagen daher auch
nicht finanziell bei uns im haushalt zu
buche das heißt im endeffekt dass die
entscheidung darüber wie familienleben
wahrgenommen und unterstützt werden
immer weniger in ihrem ressort getroffen
werden frau ministerin das ist das in
ihrem sinne müssen sie das nicht ändern
das ministerium trägt den namen
bundesministerium für familie senioren
frauen und jugend familien stehen nicht
nur ganz vorne sie sollten das auch so
repräsentieren denn ohne familie ist
kein staat zu machen so kann ein staat
nicht funktionieren wenn die familie
nicht funktionieren doch was brauchen
familien
und welche familien wollen wir mit
unserer politik insgesamt unterstützen
wie soll familienpolitik zielgenauen
effektiv sein familie wenn sie letzten
endes unbestimmt es so nahezu beliebig
wert das heißt das dann ist es nur noch
ein aspekt der sozialpolitik wir als
union wollen dass es den familien gut
geht allen familien alle mitglieder
einer familie wir wissen dass die
familien oft erheblichen belastung
ausgesetzt sind gerade jetzt vor dem
hintergrund steigender preise und der
krise und dem krieg in der ukraine
unsere aufgabe als politiker muss es
deshalb sein die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen zu stellen
wahlfreiheit zu ermöglichen und nutze
macht sich für familie für
verbindlichkeit und für auch für kinder
zu entscheiden aber ohne ideologie und
ohne bevormundung die aufgabe des
staates ist der besondere schutz von ehe
und familie
so jedenfalls unsere auffassung und auch
ihre unterstützung der staat hilft den
eltern ihre verantwortung für kinder zu
übernehmen und auch sich dass kinder
sich auch um ihre eltern kümmern der
starb er kann nicht liebe er gehört
nicht an den küchentisch aber er kümmert
sich im eigenen interesse er setzt die
rahmenbedingungen für infrastruktur für
zeit und viel geld wenn sie planen
insbesondere wirtschaftlich schwächere
familien mehr zu unterstützen dann
findet das selbstverständlich unsere
zustimmung aber in den
haushaltsberatungen hier findet sich
davon nichts und was ist mit allen
anderen familien und ihren kindern wie
stehen sie zur höhe des kindergeldes und
der kinderfreibeträge
wir fordern daher eine überprüfung und
anpassung der besteuerung und der
versicherungsbeiträge von familien
familien brauchen auch eine
infrastruktur fest steht dass immer
weniger familien sich für drei oder mehr
kinder entscheiden warum sind kinder bei
uns nicht wirklich willkommen sind sie
eine last ein armutsrisiko ein grund für
einschränkungen kinder sind ein geschenk
und familien mit kindern ein gewinn für
die gesellschaft ist die unterstützende
infrastruktur dafür unzureichend wir
haben als union in der letzten
legislaturperiode beispielsweise in der
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
einen guten grundstein mit der spd
zusammen gelegt jetzt heißt es aber
weiterhin mit zusätzlichen finanzhilfen
den kommunen dabei hilfestellungen zu
geben betreuungsangebote zu schaffen und
aus kitas gute kitas zu machen familien
brauchen aber auch eins und das ist zeit
eine flexiblere zeiteinteilung für beide
elternteile das fängt bei
familienfreundlichen arbeitszeiten an
das geht über modelle beim elterngeld
home office möglichkeiten und behörden
bei der förderung von haushaltsnahen
dienstleistungen nicht auf von einer
neugestaltung beim elterngeld oder nur
einer ernsthaften ausweitung der
partnermonate fehlt auch in diesem
haushalt jede spur liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie sie sehen ist nicht nur die
liste der versprechen in den
wahlprogrammen von dem koalitionsfrage
und im koalitionsvertrag der ampel lang
auch die berechtigten wünsche und
bedürfnisse der familien sind zahlreich
die cdu csu fraktion erwartet dass sie
noch erheblich nacharbeiten sowie sie
dass sie angekündigt haben der
haushaltsentwurf ist nicht optimal
ja
und es folgt für die spd-fraktion die
kollegin josephine ordnen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
einer spiegel sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen es fühlt sich toll an nach
längerer zeit wieder hier zu sein nach
der geburt meines sohnes haben mich
unendlich viele glückwünsche erreicht
und ich möchte die chance nutzen an
dieser stelle auch danke dafür zu sagen
gemeinsam mit meinem sohn der
hoffentlich in meinem büro gerade gut
schläft lerne ich den parlaments alltag
noch mal mit ganz anderen augen kennen
für mich ist das hier relativ gut zu
vereinbaren und zu organisieren viel
besser als für millionen von frauen die
sich fragen wie sie arbeit familie und
einfach das leben unter einen hut
bekommen sollen um so verletzen da muss
es für diese millionen von frauen sein
wenn sie hier im hause immer wieder und
wir haben es oft besonders spielern ist
heute schon gehört behauptet wird dass
mit der gleichberechtigung sei doch
längst schon erreicht wir bräuchten
keine kampagnen keine quoten keine
frauenförderung mehr wir seien doch alle
gleich so die theorie nur liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was nützt uns
frauen die theorie wenn wir in der
praxis auf so viele hürden stoßen
theoretisch können wir frauen
führungspositionen übernehmen aber
praktisch kriegt die beförderung dann
doch der männliche kollege theoretischen
wollen wir uns politisch engagieren aber
praktisch sind abendtermine mit kindern
kaum machbar theoretisch sollte es
keinen unterschied machen welches
geschlecht man hat wie man aussieht oder
wen man liebt aber praktisch macht es
eben doch ein unterschied es reicht uns
nicht theoretisch gleichberechtigt zu
sein wenn am ende unser kontostand
geringer ist um unsere renten kleiner
sind
deswegen brauchen wir einen haushalt der
frauen in deutschland stärkt einen
haushalt der hürden abbaut und einen
haushalt der alle sieht ein beispiel
sind für mich dafür vor allen dingen
auch die mittel des die für die
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
eingestellt sind die mit ihrer arbeit
wirklich menschen mut macht sich gegen
diskriminierung zu wehren diese arbeit
sollten wir künftig finanziell stärker
stellen
ganz besonders freut sich außerdem dass
wir die bundesstiftung für
gleichstellung wachsen lassen ich glaube
da geht auch noch mehr aus meiner sicht
und auch die vielen frauenverbände und
frauenorganisationen müssen wir
unterstützen denn ihre expertise für
gleichstellung für gute
gleichstellungspolitik ist von
unschätzbarem wert und
trotz der aktuellen herausforderung
werden wir die finanziellen mittel die
wir noch in der letzten vorhaben planung
angestoßen haben werden diese mittel so
jetzt auch kommen denn auch in
krisenzeiten dürfen mutige große
schritte in richtung einer gerechteren
zukunft nicht fehlen
deswegen
einzelaktionen so wichtig und ich freue
mich immer auf die beratung mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen und vor allem
auf die zusammenarbeit mit meiner
kollegin elisabeth kaiser denn klar ist
was jetzt nicht passieren darf ein
rückwärts zeitung in alte rollenmuster
unsere aufgabe als parlamentarier innen
ist es deshalb frauen zu stärken und
ihnen zu zeigen wir sehen euch wir sehen
eure leistungen wir sehen eure
erschöpfung und wir greifen euch unter
die arme wir kümmern uns darum dass ihr
nicht an den herd getränk werdet wenn
ihr das gar nicht wollte wir schaffen
die rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen damit
aus der theorie endlich praxis wird wir
geben euch die sicherheit und über euer
leben selbst zu bestimmen
politisch heißt das für uns als spd
fraktion wir müssen gleichstellung in
allen gesetzgebungs bereichen denken
deswegen freue ich mich auf den
gleichstellung stack und dass wir die
ressortübergreifende gleichstellung
strategie weiterführen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen mit diesem haushaltsentwurf
haben wir die chance politisch endlich
dahin zu kommen wo die gesellschaft
längst ist und die konservativen
parteien das haben wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode echt erlebt hier im
haus leider nie waren die botschaft die
am ende von diesem haushalt ausgehen
muss an frauen in deutschland ist jetzt
erst recht wir kämpfen für euch und wir
kämpfen für den fortschritt vielen dank
josefine ortlepp war das für die spd
fraktion
ist sie mitglied im ausschuss für
familie senioren frauen und die
abgeordnete der fraktion liebe zu singen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin meine damen und
herren eigentlich gehört die familie die
kernzelle unserer gesellschaft an die
erste stelle ich sage eigentlich denn
wenn man sich anschaut wie ihr haushalt
aufgestellt ist kann man sagen dass sie
und ihre regierung die wertschätzung der
familien in deutschland nicht zu hoch
ansetzen eher im gegenteil ein minus von
630 millionen euro gegenüber 20 21 das
sind die nackten zahlen ein minus von
630 millionen in zeiten wo viele
familien die von ihnen verursachten
kostenexplosionen ausbaden müssen ich
spreche von benzinpreisen die jenseits
aller vorstellung liegen von der
kostenexplosion bei strom und heizung
ein durchschnittshaushalt kann dieses
jahr mit einer preissteigerung von 2000
euro rechnen und das alles ist erst der
anfang es wird noch schlimmer das ist
das resultat ihrer politik die politik
politik der altparteien der letzten
jahre der vorgeschlagene haushalt liest
sich wie ein schlechter scherz für die
familienstadt die familien für die
bereits bestehende und auf uns
zukommende krise zu wappnen und
finanziell zu entlasten werden völlig
falsche anreize gesetzt auf der einen
seite an seite gibt es nämlich den
geldsegen den millionenfachen geldsegen
für maßnahmen zur stärkung von vielfalt
toleranz und demokratie
klingt alles auf dem papier schön mehr
demokratie fördern toll dahinter
verstecken sich dann aber vielfach
fragwürdige organisation wie die antonio
amodeo stiftung der vorsitzende eine
ehemalige inoffizielle stasi
mitarbeiterin war
persönliche organisation sind immer
183 millionen euro vorgesehen ein plus
von satten 33 millionen gegenüber dem
vorjahr und das mitten in der krise so
was muss man sich leisten wollen wir von
der art die sagen hier ganz klar nein
denn sie sparen bäumen angebracht
beispielsweise unserem antrag zu folgen
um das kindergeld für im ausland lebende
kinder endlich zu indexieren so etwas
kann doch nicht sein dass ein kind das
in rumänien oder polen auf werks mit dem
gleichen kindergeld ausgestattet wird
wie einst das in münchen lebt das meine
damen und herren ist ungerecht das
kindergeld soll ich das einkommen mehr
selbst ein beziehungs dass kinder
beziehungsweise einen anreiz für
sozialtourismus darstellen das erkannte
bereits der alte chef der spd sigmar
gabriel 2016 also kurz vor seinem
politischen aus und forderte genau das
was wir als ard schon länger fordern und
so macht es übrigens auch österreich wo
kürzen sie stattdessen richtig bei den
schwächsten der schwachen bei den
beiträgen zu den jugendwerken da zum
teil mehr als um die hälfte auch bei der
fachkräfte offensive ebenso um 50
millionen gekürzt beziehungsweise das
programm läuft jetzt aus haben wir etwa
kein fachkräftemangel mehr hat die
offensive dann ihre ziele erreicht er
nicht wenn man sich die arbeitsmarktlage
anschaut wieder wurde geld verbrannt für
nichts und wo wir beim geld verbrennen
sind müssen wir auch über den
unterhaltsvorschuss sprechen an sich da
sind wir uns hoffentlich alle einig eine
wichtige aufgabe des sozialstaates
kinder sollen nicht auf ihre unter ihren
unterhaltsansprüchen sitzen bleiben nur
weil ein elternteil sich weigert zu
zahlen nur der staat sollte dann aber
auch dieses geld von diesen eltern
wiederholen der bundesrechnungshof und
auch der rechnungsprüfungsausschuss
haben hier in das ministerium schon
mehrmals angemahnt und ich sehe immer
noch keine fortschritte eine milliarde
euro wird ausgegeben eingetrieben werden
lediglich 150 millionen beziehungsweise
15 prozent der bund macht hier also 850
millionen euro - im jahr geld das
anderswo fehlt das kann doch nicht sein
ich fasse zusammen ihre politik ist es
die dazu beiträgt dass sich immer
weniger menschen für eine
familiengründung entscheiden statt eine
politik zu machen die die familien
entlastet legen sie diesen noch
zusätzlich steine in den weg freuen
dürfen sich lediglich ihre
parteikollegen so ein haushalt können
wir als auf den nicht mittragen wir
werden in den haushaltsberatungen sehen
ob sie offen für sinnvolle vorschläge
sind ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
und das wort erhält für die fdp-fraktion
der kollege matthias seestern pauly
er ist der familienpolitische sprecher
der liberalen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte ministerin meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen zu oft wurden
in der vergangenheit die interessen von
familien kindern und jugendlichen
zurückgestellt und die korona pandemie
hat die situation für viele noch einmal
deutlich verschärft hinzu kommt nun die
wirklich dramatische situation der
ukrainischen familien und kinder die vor
dem russischen angriffskrieg fliegen wir
müssen die schutzsuchenden
schnellstmöglich versorgen und
integrieren und die kinder in unsere
schulen und kitas aufnehmen und ja das
stellt den bund und auch die länder vor
allem aber unsere fachkräfte in den
einrichtungen dem ich an dieser stelle
von herzen dank sagen möchte vor riesige
herausforderungen
hier alle wir alle wissen dass die
schulen und die kitas schon in der
korona pandemie stark belastet wurden
und es nun zusätzlich werden meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ist es deshalb
auch richtig dass wir mit dem von der
ampel koalition eingebrachten haushalt
erste neue schwerpunkte für die zukunft
setzen und dazu gehört natürlich auch
dass dieser haushalt dem wir nun
vorliegen knapp eine halbe milliarde
über dem liegt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der union den sie noch mit
eingebracht haben und das zieht sich in
der mittelfristigen finanzplanung sofort
das vielleicht mal zur erinnerung und
damit und dem angekündigten ergänzungs
haushalt zeigen hier
dass sich in der familienpolitik nun
etwas ändern wird und wie auch in neuen
krisen handlungsfähig sind lassen sie
mich deshalb kurz auf einige wenige
aspekte eingehen erster ich begrüße es
sehr dass die mittel für den kinder- und
jugendplan steigen und auch die frühen
hilfen weiter gestärkt werden
zweitens
stichwort sprach kitas auch hier werden
die mittel deutlich erhöht und das ist
auch richtig so denn sprache ist der
schlüssel zur integration und teilhabe
drittens stichwort engagement und
ehrenamt wir alle wissen wie wichtig
ehrenamt für unsere gesellschaft ist
deshalb werden wir mit diesem haushalt
programme fördern die sich hier auf
konzentrieren gerade in der aktuellen
zeit werbe ich für das programm menschen
stärken menschen das sich bewährt und
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
gestärkt hat deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir dieses programm nun mit
zusätzlichen mitteln ausstatten viertens
stichwort elterngeld auch hier gibt es
eine weiterhin positive entwicklung
jedoch haben wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag unter anderem bei den
partner monaten noch mehr vorgenommen
auch muss das elterngeld weiter
vereinfacht und digitalisiert werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren sie
sehen bereits nach kurzer zeit machen
wir viele schritte in die richtige
richtung aber klar ist auch dass wir
gerade erst am anfang und noch lange
nicht am ziel sind
abschließend und das ist mir ein
persönliches anliegen auch nach dieser
debatte möchte ich noch zwei sätze sagen
auch wirklich kurz ich muss sagen ich
bin jetzt seit vier jahren im bereich
fsj unterwegs dass herr raich hat mit
seiner polemik
die debatte regelmäßig nach unten zieht
das ist nichts neues wir sollten aber
das bitte ich jetzt wirklich als appell
aufzustehen und darüber gedanken machen
jeder der sich angesprochen fühlt ob es
richtig ist wirklich mit billigen
anwürfen das niveau so zur auszurollen
hier sehe ich habe mit ihnen rede ich
gerade gar nicht erreicht sondern es
geht uns im endeffekt herum die familien
um die kinder und um die jugendliche und
das sollte unser schwerpunkt sein
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also jeder mag hier um hohes niveau
ringend da sind wir sehr dafür und dass
die nächste chance bekommt heidi
reicheneck für die linke
die frauenpolitische sprecherin der
linken
[Applaus]
das doch ein guter start sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
ministerin ich habe jetzt in den letzten
sechs jahren mit kindern und
jugendlichen gearbeitet die nicht auf
der sonnenseite des lebens stehen und
deswegen bin ich schockiert dass der
vorliegende haushalt als einzige
neuerung einen mangelhaften kinder
sofort zuschlag bietet für den sich die
kolleginnen der ampel dafür aber umso
kräftiger auf die schulter klopfen den
kindern kurzen schlag bekommen 2,9
millionen kinder im leistungsbezug
prinzipiell eine gute sache aber der
zuschlag kommt weder sofort sondern erst
im juli noch wird er den im
gesetzentwurf genannten zielgerecht ich
zitiere dazu beizutragen die
lebensumstände und chancen der kinder zu
verbessern
wie auch bei einer höhe von 20 euro das
gleich noch nicht mal die aktuellen
preissteigerungen und corona bedingten
mehrbedarf von der grundlegenden
problematik der kinderarmut ganz zu
schweigen 20 euro wie kommt man auf
diesen betrag zuerst hört man ja aus dem
grünen familienministerium lächerliche
25 euro dann dachte man sicher schlimmer
kann es nicht mehr werden und dann kam
das spd geführte arbeitsministerium und
kontakte mit erbärmlichen 10 euro das
haben sie vielleicht vergessen aber ich
lasse sie nicht vergessen ist dass der
respekt den sie auch privat vergaberecht
leistet haben
jetzt sind wir bei 20 euro liebe
kolleginnen die sozialverbände hatten
für einen wirksamen sofort zuschlag eine
zahlung von mindestens 78 euro gefordert
wurde das überhaupt diskutiert wurden
die bedürfnisse von kindern jugendlichen
und familien berücksichtigt oder nur in
vorauseilendem gehorsam die der fdp zwar
werden mal eben über nacht 100
milliarden für aufrüstung aus dem boden
gestampft für den kinder sofort zuschlag
gibt es aber nur rund 380 millionen
nicht mal 0,4 prozent des
sondervermögens dass es für rheinmetall
gibt sieben kolleginnen dieser sofort
zuschlag ist respektlos mehr noch ich
etwas das für die höhe einer zukünftigen
kindergrundsicherung bedeutet
bürokratieabbau das traue ich der fdp
regierung durchaus zu aber um kinder aus
der armut zu holen braucht es schlicht
und ergreifend mehr geld für gesundes
essen für warme kleidung zur teilhabe
und wo wäre das geld besser angelegt als
bei unserer kinder frau ministerin ich
freue mich dass sie wieder gesund sind
und ich weiß auch sie waren einen
höheren kinder sofort zuschlag auch sie
waren eine kindergrundsicherung die den
namen verdient hat also setzt sie sich
in der regierung dafür ein sie haben uns
an ihrer seite
sagt heidenreich innig ganz klar hier
für die linksfraktion ja der kinder
sofort zuschlag schon mehrfach hier
thema soll ja monatlich 20 euro betragen
ab dem ersten juli ausgezahlt werden so
lange bis irgendwann die kinder
grundsicherung eingeführt wird auf die
sicher spd grüne und fdp im
koalitionsvertrag verständigt haben
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin wehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger
seit dem 24 februar 2022 ist unsere welt
eine ahnung
wir haben ihnen letzten wochen hier in
diesem haus zu recht viel über
waffenlieferungen und sanktionen
gesprochen
jetzt müssen wir familien und kinder
sprechen die zu uns fliehen wir müssen
die kindern aus der ukraine schnell
einen platz in unseren
kindertagesstätten bieten und sie müssen
die ehrenamtlichen unterstützen die mit
so viel kraft helfen egal ob am berliner
hauptbahnhof oder in ueckermünde
was müssen wir dafür tun erstens wir
brauchen sofort maßnahmen für unsere
kindertagesstätten wer die familien aus
der ukraine eine perspektive geben will
muss jetzt die kitas vorbereiten und für
ausreichend kita personalsorgen sie
benötigen ein erster schritt
niedrigschwellige angebote um die kinder
an die kitas heranzuführen dafür können
wir erfolgreiche programme wie kita
einstieg und griffbereit nutzen als
zweiten schritt werden wir die kinder
die übrigens ein rechtsanspruch auf
einen kita platz haben in unseren kitas
aufnehmen hierfür müssen wir mehr
personal bereitstellen wir müssen
schnell handeln
schnelle anerkennung ukrainische
abschnitte für erzieherin zusätzliche
mittel damit angehende erzieherinnen in
den kitas unterstützen können
zusätzliche plätze für den
freiwilligendienst in kindertagesstätten
eine verantwortungsgemeinschaft
personalgewinnung aus bund ländern
kommunen trägern und gewerkschaften
und wir brauchen endlich die schulgeld
freiheit in ganz deutschland
niemand im land kann verstehen dass
gerade in der jetzigen situation immer
noch junge menschen geld dafür zahlen
müssen damit die erzieherinnen werden
können
zweitens wir müssen die ehrenamtlichen
in deutschland unterstützen wir sehen
seit wochen die ehrenamtliche
helferinnen und helfer unglaubliches für
die ankommende geflüchteten leisten
unzählige initiativen vereine und
einzelpersonen helfen ganz praktisch
stellen wohnraum zur verfügung und
spenden ich möchte mich dafür auch im
namen der spd-fraktion ganz herzlich bei
ihnen bedanken
die ehrenamtliche in deutschland sind
das rückgrat unserer zivilgesellschaft
die bürgerinnen und bürger wollen aktiv
sein sie wollen helfen unsere aufgabe
ist als bunt ist es dafür zu sorgen dass
sie bei diesem engagement nicht alleine
gelassen werden für viele vereine und
initiativen ist die deutsche stiftung
für engagement ehrenamt ein wichtiger
partner der start der stiftung
stiftungsarbeit während der kuba
pandemie war alles andere als einfach
alleine 2020 wurden über
12.500 anträge bearbeitet die vereine
haben das achtfache des budgets von 20
millionen euro beantragt das achtfache
es ist eindeutig der bedarf es
wesentlich höher als das budget der
stiftung deswegen stellen wir zehn
millionen euro mehr zur verfügung
für mich steht fest die stiftung ist
unser wichtigstes instrument um das
ehrenamt in deutschland schnell und
unbürokratisch zu unterstützen
lassen sie uns deshalb gemeinsam in den
nächsten wochen prüfen welche
zusätzlichen aufgaben die stiftung für
die unterstützung der ehrenamtlichen
hilfe für familien aus der ukraine
übernehmen kann liebe frau minister riet
spiegel in dieser schwierigen situation
arbeiten sie daran das ehrenamt und die
kindertagesstätten zu unterstützen gut
vorzubereiten
in diesen verhandlungen übernehmen wir
gemeinsam mit ihm als abgeordnete
verantwortung ich verspreche ihnen und
ich verspreche allen bürgerinnen und
bürgern
wir werden den nächsten woche alles
dafür tun damit die zu uns linie
familien gut und sicher bei uns ankommen
dankeschön
sagt erik von malottki von der spd und
erhält dafür
beifall vor allem natürlich aus seiner
fraktion
jetzt hören wir mal wie es weitergeht
hier
zum einzelplan ja der letzte ich habe
schon mal darauf hinweisen dass wir in
ungefähr einer guten halben stunde ja
ich hier noch die schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz haben nochmal mit
bundesfinanzminister
lindner unter anderem aber jetzt ab
rednerpult erstmal an jansen für die
union
genau zwei jahren beschloss der deutsche
bundestag
umfangreiche hilfspakete um die
negativen folgen der pandemie
abzumildern eine einzigartige
neuverschuldung von
156 milliarden euro sie applaudierten
hier im hohen hause den heldinnen und
helden des alltags die das leben im
ersten locker mit ihrer systemrelevanten
arbeit aufrecht erhielten aber wo stehen
wir heute nach zwei jahren in der
pandemie als lehrerin sehe ich kinder
mit großem lärm und ständen als mutter
sähe ich familien die auch heute noch
mit den belastungen durch garantien und
dem eigenen beruf am limit sind und als
tochter sehe ich seniorinnen und
senioren die zum teil noch immer
isoliert leben und als krankenschwester
sehe ich fliegende die sich immer noch
für ihre patienten auf opfern heute
genau zwei jahre später liegt uns der
einzelplan 17 des bundeshaushaltes vor
der bereits ein 47 millionen euro mehr
enthält als noch der erste
regierungsentwurf im letzten jahr das
ist im gesamten zwar nur ein winziger
zuwachs freut mich aber dennoch sehr für
jede einzelne empfängerin und jeden
einzelnen empfänger denn eines ist
sicher jeder der insgesamt 12,6
milliarden euro der zur unterstützung
unserer familien seniorinnen und
senioren frauen und jugendlichen
ausgegeben wird ist gut investiertes
geld sicher
ist aber auch dass es zur stärkung und
förderung unserer gesellschaft immer
mehr mittel sein könnten lassen sie uns
das augenmerk also weniger auf die
zahlen und dafür mehr auf den inhalt und
die geplanten maßnahmen und deren
wirksamkeit lenken oder konkreter gesagt
lassen sie uns auf den nicht inhalt und
die fehlenden maßnahmen und deren nötige
wirksamkeit schauen denn eines fällt mir
besonders auf eine zielgruppe und das
ist heute auch deutlich geworden wird
vom für sie zuständigen wie so häufig
nur der vollständigkeit halber erwähnt
meine damen und herren die seniorinnen
und senioren
was schwer nachvollziehbar ist wenn wir
bedenken dass diese menschen unsere
eltern unsere großeltern ehemalige
kolleginnen und kollegen lehrerinnen und
lehrer oder erzieherinnen und erzieher
sind frauen und männer die uns geprägt
haben die in unser land seinen heutigen
wohlstand verdankt und die ich erwähnte
es eingangs wichtige soziale strukturen
dauerhaft verloren haben einsamkeit
ihrer auswirkung und der umgang mit ihr
bestimmten in den letzten jahren zu
recht die öffentliche diskussion und
deswegen erklären sie mir bitte in allen
betroffenen warum dieses
gesellschaftlich bedeutende problem zwar
in fast allen regierungsprogramm
prominent mit einer forderung nach einer
umfassenden strategie zu finden war im
koalitionsvertrag dann aber bis in die
aufzählungen wegverhandelt wurde in
ihrem einzelklagen willst dann auch
diese funktion nicht weiter wie
eigentlich alle vorhaben aus ihrer
wunschliste namens mehr fortschritt
waren sucht man die umsetzung vergebens
immerhin wollen sie die rolle der
älteren generation stärken und deren
wertvolles erfahrungswissen in die
gesellschaft einbringen langfristig
wollen sie unserer gesellschaft sie zu
einem aktiven leitbild einen leitbild
des aktiven alterns neu definieren eine
sehr lobenswerte absicht konkrete
maßnahmen zur umsetzung suchte ich dann
aber auf den folgenden 113 seiten des
einzelplan 17 erfolglos dabei benötigen
gerade langfristige vorhaben hin zu
einem gesellschaftlichen wandel viel
zeit die sie nicht verlieren sollten
also worauf warten sie die union war in
den letzten legislatur und insbesondere
während der korona pandemie eine starke
stimme der älteren generation von
unseren umfangreichen
positionspapieren können sie sich bei
ihrer arbeit sehr gern inspirieren
lassen
und auch wie von uns finanzierte
förderung der mehrgenerationenhäuser
legte schon vor jahren den grundstein
für ihren wunsch nach einem neuen
leitbild auf nach einem neuen leitbild
und davon konnte ich mich in meinem
wahlkreis bereits persönlich überzeugen
ein ebenso bedeutendes element sozialer
teilhabe aller generationen ist das seit
60 jahren bewährte erfolgsmodell des
bundesfreiwilligendienstes er stärkt den
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft
zwischen den generationen und bereichert
das ganze weitere leben der engagierten
jugendlichen und selbstverständlich hat
die union dieses engagement als
unverzichtbare investition in die
zukunft der sozialen berufe in der
letzten legislatur stärkung mit 65
millionen euro unterstützt mit großer
sorge musste ich feststellen dass sie
diesen wert offenbar weniger bedeutend
einschätzen wie sonst erklären sie die
faktische kürzung der fördermittel ab 20
24 planungssicherheit ist für gewachsene
strukturen wichtige basis und
grundvoraussetzung mittel können nur
dann sinnvoll eingesetzt werden wenn sie
auch durch verpflichtungsermächtigungen
in den folgejahren abgesichert werden
und wenn die verstetigung nicht jetzt